[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show like
yesterday is James clear you can find
him on Twitter and Instagram jamesclear
James is a writer and speaker focused on
habits and continuous Improvement he's
the author of the number one New York
Times Mega bestseller I'm adding the
mega Atomic habits which covers easy and
proven ways to build good habits and
break bad ones the book has sold more
than 10 million copies worldwide and has
been translated into more than 50
languages on average atomic habits has
sold one copy every 15 seconds since it
was published so by the time I finish
reading this intro two or three copies
will have been sold James is also the
creator of the three two one newsletter
that's three hyphen two hyphen one
newsletter which is one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
that has more than 2 million subscribers
each issue contains three short ideas
from James two quotes from other people
and one question to consider it that
week we're going to talk a lot about
questions in fact shortly with James you
can sign up for free at jamesclear.com
he is a regular speaker at Fortune 500
companies and his work is used by
players and coaches in the NFL NBA and
MLB in college he was an academic
All-American baseball player and he is
an avid weightlifter for those who
cannot see the video we seem to go to
the same stylist we've got the Sam
Hansen bald look and the same long
sleeve dark shirt look and you can find
James at jamesclear.com and as mentioned
on Twitter and Instagram at James Clear
James it is nice to see you hey great to
talk to you thank you so much for the
opportunity
absolutely I'm thrilled to be having
this conversation and I thought we would
start with something that's also on my
mind but the topic of annual reviews
comes up for some people once a year and
we are now winding down on this year
about to head into the new year could
you please describe your annual reviews
and perhaps just walk us through the
process and also describe or explain why
for at least a period of time you
published all of these publicly you can
tackle that in any order of your life so
you know it's nice to have a process for
a reflection review I actually think
yeah I'm sure we'll talk a lot about
habits in this conversation and one of
the kind of meta habits that's really
helpful is some kind of habit of
reflection review because it allows you
to course correct nobody sets out to get
off course or to make a mistake or to do
something that goes against their values
but we just kind of have this natural
drift in life and as time goes on we
kind of find ourselves situations where
maybe we're not doing the optimal thing
anymore and an annual review is the
chance to check in I also think it's
helpful to have shorter Cycles to review
so like on Fridays I usually do some
kind of short little business review
where I look at revenue and expenses and
new email subscribers and stuff like
that but at the end of each year I like
to ask myself some big questions I'm
glad you started here because I think
that questions can be very useful if you
ask better questions you can get better
answers but also questions are very
resilient they're very adaptable to the
context and that's something that's
different and perhaps a little bit
better than advice you know advice is
actually kind of brittle and context
dependent somebody can have a really
good plan a really good piece of advice
to give you but if it doesn't fit your
context then it's actually not great
advice for your particular situation
whereas questions are very adaptable so
I think maybe what I should do is just
go through some of the questions that I
like to ask myself for my annual review
and and throughout the the rest of the
year so I guess we could say this first
category is just kind of like questions
that help improve self-awareness or help
kind of bringing back to Center so like
the first thing and I think actually
this might be a question from Derek
sivers or some version of it from him
just what am I optimizing for
you know sometimes people optimize for
money sometimes optimize for free time
sometimes they optimize for Creative
output or being able to choose the
projects they work on all kinds of stuff
but that answer probably changes over
time what I'm optimizing for today is
different than what I was optimizing for
five years ago or ten years ago so I
think it's a helpful question to keep
revisiting and you need to decide what
it is for you otherwise it's easy to
kind of slide into this status signaling
or just kind of like doing the things
that you feel like you're encouraged to
do by Society or by your friends or
peers or your parents or whatever
so what am I optimizing for another way
of phrasing that is maybe like what's
the real objective here like what am I
actually trying to achieve so some
version of that question
I also like does this activity fill me
with energy or drain me of energy you
can tell a lot just by whether it like
fills up your cup or not and ideally
you'll be spending more time in the next
year on things that fill you with energy
and less time on things that drain you
with energy
speaking of the things that drain you
maybe like a sub question that I like to
keep in mind is does the amount of
attention I'm giving this match its true
importance and man there's so many years
when I find that I'm giving something a
lot of attention that actually is not
that important are you asking these
questions as you're going through the
calendar of your past year in what set
of circumstances or what context are you
asking this question or are these just
broadly speaking questions that you're
applying
more or less all the time for
self-awareness and different types of
Cycles I don't think you need to wait
and only do it once a year but right
when I am asking these questions for the
end of review I usually am writing like
maybe a paragraph for each one and it's
almost like a journaling prompt and I do
have things that I check for this
process there's a lot of measurement so
to speak that happens throughout the
year even if you aren't thinking about
it that way so for example my calendar
measures how many new cities I went to
or how many nights I spend away from
home those are kind of important things
how do you do that oh I see it measures
it meaning it logs it right like I can
see like oh I was in Dallas from Tuesday
to Thursday and so because I know that I
was there then I'm like well that was
two nights or three nights where I
wasn't sleeping in my own bed and so
then at the end of the year I try to
figure out how many nights did I spend
away from home is that more than I want
to spend is it less you know like how
did that fall for the year yep totally I
write down my workouts in an actual
Journal like a pen and paper Journal so
I've got all the sets logged I have how
many workouts I did and then I can look
back on the dates how many workouts I do
for each month what was the average
number of workouts per month so a lot of
that stuff I'm not thinking about
tracking it throughout the year but it's
kind of there for me as I sit down to
review the year those measurements are
there as I'm kind of going through these
questions and then trying to figure out
where did I direct my attention what am
I optimizing for am I spending my energy
on things that fill me up or things that
drain me
another question that I think is helpful
is if once you answer what am I
optimizing for you can ask yourself can
my current habits carry me to my desired
future
and that's really about figuring out
what kind of trajectory you're on and if
they can then maybe all you need is
patience but if they can't something
needs to change you know like you need
to develop or build some new habits
another question I love and this is
actually at the core of a lot of what I
talk about in atomic habits is how can I
create an environment that will
naturally bring about my desired change
rather than trying to like fight this
and force my way through rather than
trying to grip my teeth and make it
happen even if the circumstances aren't
ideal how can I look around and
structure my physical environment my
social environment and the tribes I'm a
part of and my strategy for what I'm
trying to achieve so that it's almost
natural that I'm moving in that
direction so I have a bunch of questions
I got like 20 that I go through but
those are just three or four that you
know kind of come to mind well we may
come back to the remainder of the list
because I am a
question junkie no big surprise there
but I wanted to maybe reference the
I should say V but one of the key points
in the first chapter of atomic habits
which is you don't rise to the level of
your goals you fall to the level of your
systems which is a modification of one
of my favorite quotes wish I could
actually speak the original language but
I cannot alas from the Greek poet and
philosopher ARCA Locus we don't rise to
the level of our expectations we fall as
the level of our training so to this
systems piece
I think about this a lot and have found
for myself and certainly for many people
in my audience that
stacking the deck so it is harder to
fail goes a lot further than trying to
rely on Willpower right and it's almost
difficult for me to imagine
precise steps you could take to hone
something that is labeled as broadly as
willpower so how can you set up
accountability how can you set up
incentives Etc what are some of the
systems that you have for
yourself
for various habits so we can pick a
couple different habits like let's take
Fitness for example and then I'll also
do it for like writing and business so
for Fitness which I consider to be this
this is kind of the one like my core
habits it's one of the ones I feel like
is most important for how I structure my
day
but I try to do whatever I can to reduce
friction and make it as easy as possible
to do it so
the first thing is I give myself
permission to reduce the scope but stick
to the schedule so if my typical workout
takes 45 minutes but I only have 15 that
day it's easy to get into this story
where you're like I don't have time to
do it all like why bother but instead I
try to remind myself to reduce the scope
but stick to the schedule and there have
been a lot of days where all I have time
for is to go in and do a couple sets of
squats but I'm glad that I did that
rather than doing nothing and accounts
for a lot to like not throw a zero up
for another day
in a sense in the long run I almost feel
like the bad days matter more than the
good days because yeah if you show up on
the bad days even if it's less than what
you had hoped for
you maintain a habit and if you maintain
the Habit then all you need is time
so it counts for a lot you also proved
yourself you know you can look at
yourself in the mirror at the end of the
night and be like you know what
circumstances weren't ideal situation
wasn't perfect but I still found a way
to show up and you know like get some
reps in today so that's the first thing
it's kind of like mindset and approach
second thing is and I've gradually
increased what I do for this so I at
first it's there's basic stuff like set
your workout clothes next year set them
out the night before have you know
everything like ready to go have your
water bottle filled up stuff like that
but I've gradually kind of reduced the
friction even more and now I used to
work at a gym for like 10 years and so I
would do all that kind of stuff now over
the last year or two I built a home gym
and so all I have to do is get down to
the basement and I can just work out
there and I'm gradually accumulating
more and more equipment you know I'm
becoming like this equipment hoarder now
I have enough stuff that like I don't
have any excuses like all I have to do
is just walk downstairs and I can be
doing that exercise in 15 seconds so
it's really just about reducing friction
some of that is strategy too if you
don't have equipment or or you don't
want to pay for a gym membership they're
great body weight programs or you could
just do 10 Sprints up and down the
sidewalk and they're like almost no
excuses if you have the right strategy
for reducing friction and just figuring
out ways to to get a decent workout I
think the reduction of scope that you
mentioned is really critical
that if you don't have time for 60 it
doesn't mean you have to go to zero and
I'm I'm guilty of this this happens to
me sometimes I'm not gonna lie but I
will also just add if you don't have
space for an entire gym you almost
certainly have space for a functional
doorstop AKA kettlebell you could get
one kettlebell or even build a
kettlebell from some basic materials you
can people can look it up a t-bar
kettlebell for swings and if you can
just do one set of swings I mean you're
gonna hit a lot and I would love to hear
well let's see a few things if you don't
mind me just yeah adding my my
commentary sure so the first is
underscoring and other thing you said
which is
I don't want to say it doesn't matter
but it matters much less what happens on
the days where you feel like doing the
things
that you have set out as your habits or
or goals behaviors Etc what matters is
what happens when you don't want to do
those things and this is where the
systems and the lack of excuses and
accountability and so on comes into play
how do you apply this well actually one
more thing which is the the exercise
piece I'm glad you brought it first and
many people might think well that's fine
that's just exercise but exercise for me
is sort of the cascading upper level of
the waterfall and if you take care of
your body your body takes care of your
brain and mood and so many other things
so in a sense it's the force multiplier
category so I'm glad we spoke about it
first what other types of
systems and I'll sort of put that in air
quotes because it could take I'm sure a
lot of different forms but what might be
examples of systems
or scaffolding that you've set up in
other areas so just a quick point on
what you just mentioned first so
I think it's worth asking yourself what
habits are Upstream from other things
that I want to do or other things that
set me up for a good day and what you're
kind of describing is that a workout
habit at least for you and I would say
for me is Upstream from a lot of other
good things that happen like I get the
benefits of the workout sure but also I
tend to have that post-workout high for
an hour or two where I get this good
period of concentration I tend to eat
better when I'm training it's kind of
like I don't want to waste it it's
actually when I'm not training that I
get lazy and you know start eating
whatever I want I tend to sleep better
at night because I'm tired from the
workout which means I wake up the next
day and I have better energy and at no
point was I trying to actively build
better sleep habits or nutrition habits
or whatever but it just kind of came as
a natural byproduct of getting that one
habit of a good workout in and it
doesn't have to be Fitness you talk to
some people you know comedians for
example we'll talk about how or athletes
will talk about how they have this
visualization habit before they step out
on the stage and if they get that in
they kind of recite what a good
performance is going to look like that
helps them perform in the moment or CEOs
will talk about a meditation habit and
if they get their 15 minutes of
meditation in the morning that sets them
up for the rest of the day being
productive so I think it just comes down
to asking yourself
when I'm living a good day when I'm on
what are some of the key habits that are
part of that and then maybe rather than
worrying about everything and trying to
hit every little Domino along the way
what's the lead Domino what's that first
action that's Upstream from the other
productive things and can I just pour my
energy into making sure I do that today
and kind of trust that the momentum will
carry me forward
okay so your question was what are some
other examples of systems it can take
many different forms it could be a
physical thing that helps you be more
productive so for example this doesn't
work for everybody's job but it works
for mine and I don't do it every day but
I probably do it 70 to or 80 of the time
which is I leave my phone in another
room until lunch each day
now it gives me a chance it gives me
space to just work on my agenda rather
than responding to everybody else's
agenda you know like I can actually show
up and have a few hours where I can do
some creative work so that's a system in
a sense it's a physical environment that
promotes or benefits The Habit that I'm
trying to build which is creative output
or writing or whatever it could be
digital things so for example each week
I write three two one this Weekly
Newsletter and there are three short
ideas for me two quotes from other
people and one question in each
newsletter and I have a spreadsheet that
has three tabs one of them is ideas one
of them is quotes and one of them is
questions and I've got hundreds of ideas
that I've generated or quotes that I've
run across and read or questions that
I've kind of like spitball and then
maybe this could be in a newsletter
sometime and because I have this system
which in this case is just this
spreadsheet of raw material it only
takes me an hour or two to write the
newsletter because I have a lot to start
from I have good starting material and
so the system of when I read a book and
come across a quote that I like I type
it down and put it into the spreadsheet
that's a very simple system but it makes
the process of writing the newsletter
each week much easier so there are many
different forms that could take them it
could be almost infinite and it's
variations but it's any way that you set
up the environment physical digital or
social to make the Habit easier and more
frictionless
let's zoom in on the creative process a
little bit and we're going to talk about
also
email us building email because I feel
as though what was old is once knew
again always it's like every few years I
have to be like guys you need a way to
communicate with your audience that
cannot be taken away from you
immediately by platform yeah email Never
Dies and everybody talks about how it's
dead yeah it's like the cat came back
the very next day we thought it was a
gun but it wouldn't stay away I mean
email
is not going anywhere anytime
immediately right so we'll come back to
that because it is a vehicle for
transmitting some of this creative work
as you described it
I have read a bit about your use or past
use of Asana for capturing ideas I think
this was for asymmetry at the time at
least in the article I read on every dot
to and then I separately read about a
600 page Google doc that you had put
together and were compressing in various
ways
where have you landed with idea capture
maybe web capture let's add that in
because it may be a separate category
what is your portfolio of tools first of
all I don't think the tool matters that
much I think what does matter is
crafting great information flows and
capturing the good ideas that you come
across and then depending on what you're
trying to do in my case I'm trying to
create books or to write newsletters
using that raw material that you
collected to create something great so I
would say the big picture game is always
the same which is first I'm trying to
craft better information flows
almost every idea that you have is
Downstream from what you consume we
don't usually think about it that way
but like when you choose who to follow
on Twitter you're choosing your future
thoughts in a sense you're creating the
information flow what the timeline what
the feed is going to look like or when
you choose what book to read or which
podcast episode to listen to you're
choosing the thoughts that are going to
arise now you may not necessarily know
what they are but over time you can
start to learn which sources of
information are higher signal than
others and I almost feel like that is
like the main Habit to try to build
especially in our current modern society
because information is overflowing and
so widely accessible the person who
creates better information flows gets
better thoughts how do you consume
what do you choose I've spent kind of an
unreasonable amount of time curating my
Twitter feed I think that makes me feel
better about spending time on it I don't
I'm not necessarily saying it's like the
best place but because I have found a
really good set of people to follow I do
get useful ideas from Twitter and it's
easy and I'm probably spending more time
on it than I should so at least now
maybe it's a little more valuable but
the single highest thing for me is when
I find a book that is relevant to what
I'm writing about if it's relevant to
the the topic and you and I mean that in
like a more granular fashion like let's
say for Atomic habits for example
I don't mean a book about habits I mean
hey I'm writing a chapter on
self-control and this book has a story
that relates to self-control or this
book has you know a piece of research
that relates to that particular chapter
and when I find the right thing it's
hard for me to even get through a page
because I'm taking so many notes and
it's sparking so many ideas to write
about like it'll take me an entire
morning just to get through like three
pages how do you find the gems that are
that dense I mean I have my own thoughts
on how I approach this but there are a
hundred thousand plus books almost a
year in the US in English alone probably
something along those lines how do you
ferret your way through the maze to find
some of those books first thing is you
gotta be willing to quit books fast if
you have baggage around finishing books
then if you feel like you have to finish
something because you started it then
you're you're just gonna be stuck and
you won't move on quickly enough there's
this quote about Emerson I think where
it says something like he read like a
hawk looking for prey like scanning over
the field and I think about that like I
try to read like that I'm not reading
for the enjoyment or like slowly
unpacking a book the way that I would
with a Sci-Fi novel or something I'm
trying to find a you know an Insight so
that's the first thing is start more
books quit most of them the second thing
is suggestions from friends are always
helpful and so if you let people know
hey I'm writing about this topic what's
the good book that I should read I have
found a couple great ones that way so
just kind of putting it out into the
universe if you find a book that's good
go to the back of the book and see what
the references are and then go through
those and just scan those books on
Amazon and a lot of the time you'll find
a couple other ones that are useful
if you find a book that had something
but you feel like maybe it didn't quite
hit it go to Amazon and check all the
three star reviews for that book or the
one star reviews sometimes and there'll
be other books recommended in there so
they say instead of reading this you
should read this one yeah so the three
star reviews is a key right because the
five star reviews are just overly a few
not overly I don't want to slam should I
start reviews I love five star reviews
but they tend to not and I would say for
me at least one star reviews are
sometimes like I ordered a toaster and
they sent me a book and you're like come
on yeah you bought a book yeah like pay
attention to what you're clicking but
the three star reviews like the most
helpful or most critical three star
reviews you tend to get a lot of really
helpful feedback I'll add two for for
folks who might just be curious because
I read for people who can see behind me
I have bookshelves and many many more
bookshelves
I will very often
go to Wikipedia and Goodreads
I will see if the book is old enough it
will very often if it's iconic enough or
it has stood the test of time which is
not true for all books that I've read or
do read but there will often be a
Wikipedia page and there will almost
always be
quotes from film blank book Goodreads if
you search that on Google you'll get a
good selection so you can get a feel for
for instance you know finite and
infinite games by cars is that something
you want to read well you could get a
very good taste test like if you don't
like the trailer for the movie you're
not gonna like the movie right so if you
don't like the Goodreads highlights
you're not going to like the book I can
almost guarantee you and side note on
that you were mentioning you know what
am I optimizing for which sounds very
much
like it could be a Derek Silver's
question he has a lot of good questions
a variant on that that I've also found
helpful is what game am I playing
we're all playing games so it's like
aside from shelter food a handful of the
basics at the very bottom of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs like we're all
playing games so what games are you
playing what are you trying to win
and becoming cognizant of that
is for me at least step one and I think
I don't know if this is a question that
you've asked before but like is that
game worth winning you know like is this
something that like am I climbing the
right mountain or do I need to be
climbing a different one because it's
very important to make sure that you're
in in the right game
yeah totally so you mentioned the tools
not mattering so much choosing the
inputs we talked about books
for capture when you're like that's good
so you're right I I do use Asana mostly
it's a very messy process and Asana is
just kind of like a holding ground for
it but I have the app on my phone and I
got it pulled up in my you know browser
all the time and so it's always right
there I don't really care what the tool
is like in this case this is what I've
been using for the last few years but it
just needs to be something that is
always present and as soon as you have
an idea it always goes into one place
you don't have to think about where
you're going to record it and you don't
end up with a random note on your iPhone
and another one in a never note Dock and
a third thing in a Google doc and you
know like now it's hard to find the
ideas if you have them all in one place
it's the story of my life right now
which is why I'm very interested in your
use of Asana because Asana I've used
Asana ton I still use yeah Asana for
project management task management but
idea capture wasn't a use case I'd
really considered so you would you mind
just for people listening explaining I
know this is
like pedestrian but like how do you do
it without stuff getting lost part of
this is again I'm trying to like
simplify things as much as possible and
this is we may talk about this more as
we kind of go through the conversation
but I have a really small team it's me
and one employee and I'm not interested
in having a large team and I want to be
as effective and as high leverage as
possible and that means that we need to
think really carefully about where we
spend our time and if I always have a
bunch of different tools or I'm always
switching between different apps that's
just time that's kind of wasted if the
job could be done in the same place and
so we use Asana to run the book launcher
to run the newsletter calendar or to you
know like for all the other stuff that
we do throughout the day and so I was
like well I can write it down here just
as well as I can write it down somewhere
else and then once it gets categorized
it goes into the appropriate dock for
that project so as an example let's say
I'm reading a book and I come across an
idea that's relevant for the newsletter
and it's a quote so I'll probably label
the task or the new thing that I put
into Asana I guess that you usually call
them tasks but I label Things based on
the project it's going to so I'll just
say quote and then I'll paste the quote
in and it's labeled and so I'll go
through all those quotes or Lindsay my
employee will go through all this quotes
and we'll put them into the spreadsheet
so they're in the right tab or let's say
the next thing I'm reading I come across
an idea that Sparks a thought for me or
I'm like oh that would fit into the next
chapter for the book and so I'll write
the idea out and then I'll label it
based on whatever the topic of the book
is so for Atomic habits the label might
be habits and so at the beginning of any
idea I come across that would fit for
the book I'll put habits and then a lot
of the time
I'll actually put like a second category
for the chapter so let's say that this
particular idea was for the chapter on
self-control it'll be habits
self-control and then I'll type the idea
out and then you know a couple times a
week I'll go through everything that's
labeled as habits and then put it in the
right place in the dock and then it's
all kind of there you could imagine one
way to do this even faster which is you
could just put it straight into the dock
that it needs to live in instead of
putting it into a sauna I could put it
straight into the 321 newsletter sheet
or I could put it straight into the
chapter for the book but I've noticed
that the problem is I got a lot of
projects going at one time and a lot of
notes from places where things could
live and so if I'm always having to
remember which thing to pull up then you
either end up with like a bazillion tabs
open or it's just as hard to remember
which things need to go where at the
exact moment when you have the idea and
a lot of the time I'll have an idea when
I'm on a walk or in the middle of a
workout and so I'm not in a position to
pull up the book manuscript I just need
to be able able to get it down and then
I can sort it later for people listening
what I'm trying to do in this
conversation we'll see how successful it
is is to zoom in and zoom out and we'll
zoom out and we'll talk about conceptual
framework or particular focal point
whether it's within the atomic habits
Paradigm or outside of it just given
what you focus on James and then zoom in
so we can take a look at how this jams
run systems or develop systems in
location acts in his life right so the
one employee small team is where I'd
like to go next sure if that's okay with
you yep
how do you
I suppose try to build systems ensure
maximal leverage with a very small team
this is always of interest to me I have
a small team it has always been of
interest to me like small Giants by Bob
Burlingame I think the subtitle is
companies that choose to be great
instead of big or something like that
I've always been
fascinated by positive constraints so
one you could set is I'm not going to
have a big deal yeah I'm not going to
hire a lot of people so then you have to
make decisions that fall in line with
optimizing not optimizing for that but
operating within that constraint sure
what are some of the productivity
principles guiding questions and so on
that you have
first I'll just say like I'm not saying
this is how everybody should run their
business it's just how I choose to run
mine and you have to choose what you're
trying to to accomplish and in my case
like I don't want to have a big team but
I do want to make as big of an impact as
possible and so the first question I ask
is like rather than optimizing for money
let's optimize for time so how do I want
to spend my days and then I try to make
as few choices as possible that violate
that answer and you got to keep coming
back to that how do I want to spend my
days what do I want my time to be spent
on and within that how can we reach the
most people possible or make the most
money possible but not without violating
that because there's like all kinds of
things you do you know I can staff up I
could build a bigger business whatever
but like I'm not interested in spending
my days like that
so that's the first thing is you got to
decide what you're trying to do
a question that I love and I keep coming
back to for increasing leverage and I
try to encourage both Lindsay and I to
think about this over and over again is
what is the work that keeps working for
us once it's done
so as an example when Atomic habits came
out I did a ton of interviews and some
of those interviews were on radio and I
don't really do radio interviews anymore
because as soon as I get done with that
10 minute segment or whatever it was
all the work that I put in it vanishes
nobody's listening anymore it's off the
air whereas a podcast like you know what
we're doing right now is being recorded
and so people can continue to listen to
it and you know I've done a bunch of
podcasts for the book and there's
somebody Somewhere listening to one of
them right now it's almost like there
are multiple versions of James out there
and they're all continuing to work right
now and that's an example of like the
work that keeps working for you once
it's done if you can do one or two
things a day that are going to keep
working for you in the long run man you
end up like two or three or five years
later and you just have this tidal wave
of previous effort that is working for
you so let me give you a couple
different examples and stories from my
personal experience
I wrote this article a couple years ago
it's called the physics of productivity
and it was just taking like you know
Newton's three laws and applying them to
productivity and kind of this I don't
know hopefully clever way
and it it did fine it didn't the article
didn't blow up or anything but it's just
kind of a normal piece and it sat there
on the site and people would
occasionally read it and then a couple
years later this journalist from The New
York Times read that article and they
were writing this piece and they linked
to the original article in it and it
wasn't much it was just like a sentence
but they they linked to the website
well there was this producer for CBS
that read the article in the New York
Times and then clicked through to my
site and sent me an email and said hey
do you want to come on CBS This Morning
and talk about this piece and so I was
like okay sure so they flew me to New
York and I did the segment and it was my
first time on TV and so I was all
nervous about it but like I tried to do
my best and you know like have a good
segment and as soon as it got done I
went over to Gail King and I said hey I
have this book coming out in 10 months
so this was like 10 months before Atomic
habits I would love to come back and do
a segment about that smart when the book
comes out and she said sure thing like
we'll have you back just make sure that
we're your first stop don't do any other
interviews on TV shows before before us
and so as soon as I left I got our email
and I sent a message to her and the
publisher and everybody and I got on the
calendar for launch day and that was how
I got on CBS This Morning for the launch
of atomic habits and that ended up being
I think a kind of an important moment
for the launch of the book because
it made it feel like a thing you know it
wasn't just a guy launching a book it
was like oh this is a bigger event and I
don't know how many books that segment
sold I've tried to calculate it probably
probably more than a thousand probably
less than ten thousand probably
somewhere in that range
but as soon as the segment got over they
put that clip on YouTube and then like
two hours later we took the YouTube clip
and emailed it out to my audience and
that was the launch email for the book
that day was like here's my second on
CBS This Morning the book is out and so
what I'm getting at is
that work of writing that article about
the physics of productivity that work
continued to work for me in really big
ways three or five or six years later
even though the initial article didn't
seem like that big of a deal and the
reason it worked out is because that was
work that kept working for me once it
was done so anytime you create an asset
that can compound a blog post a podcast
episode even simple stuff like Twitter
posts and Instagram posts are less
likely because they kind of have a short
half-life but even those can be examples
of putting a work out there that is
still being recorded and still being
stumbled across by people online and
you're creating a large surface area for
good things to kind of break your way if
you spend time doing that now I think
you can even do better than that which
is not only can you create assets that
compound and keep working for you you
can do it in a way where they layer on
top of each other so
I'll spend 20 minutes on a tweet and
that seems kind of like an excessive
amount of time to spend writing you know
two sentences but the time that I put
into that I'll put it out there and it's
its own little asset and then maybe if
it does well I'm like hey we should use
that in the newsletter and so it goes in
the newsletter and then maybe it becomes
the seed of an idea for a longer chapter
or an article in a book or something or
it gets added to related ideas that can
become something bigger
and so now that 20 minutes is actually
doing a lot more work than just gaining
a few Twitter followers and if you can
find ways to layer those little assets
on top of each other then you get three
or five or six years down the line and
you really have a dramatic effect so
those are a couple different ways to
kind of like try to operate in a high
leverage way with a really small team
in the last week we're recording this
towards the end of December 2022.
Twitter is one example has made a number
of changes that have
suspended a number of my Twitter
accounts and there's no explanation
provided no particular
bad behavior that I or my team can
identify but suspended nonetheless and
then they get reinstated and then two
days later they'll get suspended again
can't figure it out but what this means
is much like when say Facebook started
I don't want to say requiring highly
encouraging boosting AKA paying for
promotion of posts
to reach your previously organic
audience
people's business models and audience
size started to effectively disintegrate
right and having email is so so valuable
which is why I'm also spending some time
on this and it's important to me so
that's just a background setting the
table so that I can ask you when
something is going wrong aside from
reaching out to say your email service
provider and saying hey this is
something funny going is something
broken is there a monkey wrench in the
world yeah how would you go about
figuring things out
I like to think about it as there's
internal distribution so those are the
things that I own and you really can
only own kind of a few assets like you
can own your website you can own your
email list you can own your podcast and
that's kind of roughly about it and then
the other bucket is external
so this is other people's platforms that
you can have Distribution on YouTube
Tick Tock Twitter Facebook
Etc
and as much as possible
I think the web is it is very
platform-centric right now and people
spend a lot of time on those platforms I
don't want to be on all of them because
I don't have enough time and energy to
be good at all of them but there are
probably a few that are a good fit for
my audience so Twitter and Instagram are
the two that we've decided to focus on
no Tick Tock dance is coming soon no
Tick Tock routines yet yeah to figure
out how to tie that into habits we'll
we'll see what comes
so I post on those two platforms and
then I try to build an audience there
but also you'll notice a lot of the
posts that I put up on there so
Instagram for example I have a very
weird Instagram account because I don't
share any pictures of myself I'm not
like not really interested in like me as
an individual being out there but it's
all about the ideas and so it's just a
bunch of text
but on many of them at the bottom of the
image or in the caption it'll say you
know here's a quote and then at the
bottom they'll say you know get more
ideas like this sign up for three two
one and then it'll have a link to the
newsletter and so the idea is to subtly
be encouraging people to go off platform
and join one of the assets or one of the
pieces of audience that I do own one of
the internal ones like the website or
the newsletter or whatever and so I try
to get those things to work together and
like cross link between the two and then
they can start to build each other and I
do it the other way as well
like when I send out a newsletter
sometimes if the ideas are short enough
and they would make a good tweet I'll
include a little link under each idea
and just say click to tweet and so now
the newsletter is driving action on
Twitter and so that it all kind of like
you create this little spider web this
kind of ecosystem where everything is
kind of driving each other and
you know it all kind of grows together
but
the ultimate idea is to try to point
back the external platforms to the
distribution sources that you do own so
that you're not beholden to any
particular one when they decide to
change their their strategy or approach
yeah which is specifically why a whole
bunch of stuff is getting banned or
Shadow banned right now on Twitter and
this is the best theory I could come up
with and I can't get this verified or
denied is that because some of these
accounts which were created for a new
podcast that came out have legitimate
contact but they all link out to Apple
podcasts it's the only plausible
explanation that we can come up with for
why they have it's been locked and they
keep getting unlocked so I don't want to
make anybody seem like the the bad guy
here but it highlights the fragility of
having something that is entirely
dependent on
a platform that you don't own and also
if you were to read your terms of
service you're probably giving all of
that content to the platform as well on
some level and I recall chatting with
this guy this is many years ago before
the organic reach was throttled a lot on
Facebook
chatting with a guy who had a
multi-million dollar business built on a
few Facebook pages and massively
successful and I asked him what it felt
like to run those businesses and he said
I feel like I have the most profitable
McDonald's in the world built on top of
an active volcano
it could go away at any minute and I
don't want to live with that anxiety
also and just add a few things just to
feather them in with your comments you
know one is
it's very important to adapt I would
I would add something to that which is
it's very important to adapt but I think
it's really critical to have a good
explanation for how you are adapting and
not to discard for the sake of
discarding and just as an example to
give people window into my thinking
Reddit and some of these other platforms
still can drive a lot of traffic but
they're not sexy and people are starting
to neglect them so there's far less
competition on some of these older let's
just call it platforms that are actually
still innovating quite well in the case
of Reddit
so I've thought about revisiting some of
the the Vintage powerhouses because
there's been such a mass migration to
particularly short form video it just
seems like a bloodbath
and I would also say something I think
you've done very well
is set constraints on what you will or
will not do say on social platforms
because one of the risks of adapting is
that you become a slave to the audience
in such a way that you morph into this
fun house mirror
caricature of yourself and I've seen
this happen to a lot of people where
they put out 10 posts and the most
extreme of those gets the most
engagement or feedback or positive
likes Etc
and so they then put out five more like
that the most extreme gets the best
response and a year later
not only has their social feed become
like the craziest like infomercial pitch
man yelling
circus but this is the greater risk is
that they they in real life have started
to become the mask that they've created
for themselves this is a very real risk
so setting up the constraints on what
you will or will not do in advance
before you get on that playing field I
think is really really at least for me
very very important how do you think
about that or have you thought about
that
well this connects to one of the core
ideas in atomic habits which is your
habits are how you embody a particular
identity so the aspects the behaviors
that you perform each day are
reinforcing or shaping the story that
you have about yourself
I think it's important to ask yourself
like who is the type of person I wish to
become you know like what's the type of
identity I want to be reinforcing and
your habits are not the only things that
influence that in life like every
experience is part of who you are but by
virtue of the fact that they get
repeated again and again you are
they have an outsized influence on your
story and so you know the phrase I like
to keep in mind is every action you take
is a vote for the type of person you
wish to become yeah that's a great line
so as you show up each day and make
another YouTube video or do another Tick
Tock video You're casting a vote for
being that kind of person and if you let
the algorithm run it if you let yourself
kind of fall into this as you said mask
that you're wearing for the audience
pretty soon you actually are like
casting enough votes that the bulk of
the evidence starts to support that part
of your identity you start to become
that kind of person and this is why I
come back to some of those questions
that we were talking about earlier like
what am I optimizing for or how do I
want to spend my days because you got to
start there and set the positive
constraints for yourself who's the type
person I wish to become what am I trying
what kind of Lifestyle am I trying to
create for myself and then within that
constraint how can I have the biggest
audience or how can I make the most
money or how can I make the biggest
impact
but yeah I think that's a way of trying
to Anchor yourself and not like lose
yourself and let the let the algorithm
kind of run the show so
I think your habits and your identity
are very connected and the actions that
you take
shape or support they provide evidence
for the type of person that you are and
so it's worth asking yourself like what
are my actions moving me closer to and
you want to make sure that you're on a
good path
may I read something from your fantastic
website so this is on identity based
habits
I want to highlight this and add it to
what you just said because I think it's
critically important and feel free to
revise any of this and you can't believe
everything you read on the internet so
who knows even if it comes from my own
website I don't think the CCP has
infiltrated your website or anything
like that so let me let me just give
this a read
the key to building lasting habits is
focusing on creating a new identity
first that's the sentence I'd love to
get your take on your current behaviors
are simply a reflection of your current
identity what you do now is a mirror
image of the type of person you believe
that you are either consciously or
subconsciously to change your behavior
for good you need to start believing new
things about yourself you need to build
identity based habits
would you like to add anything to that
the the creating a new identity first is
I think the
the piece that is of greatest
interesting how would somebody go about
doing that let's say
they're listening to this they're just
moving into the new year
James please tell me how do I do this
well it's kind of a two-step process
decide the type of person you want to be
and then you prove it to yourself with
small wins and the more small wins the
more small habits that you
perform
the more votes that you cast for that
identity the more you build up evidence
of being that kind of person and
eventually you start to take pride in
that aspect of your identity and man
once we start to take pride in a part of
our story like it's much easier to stick
with those habits if you take pride in
the size of your biceps you'll like
never skip arm day at the gym you know
or if you take pride in how your hair
looks you have this like long hair care
routine all these Hair Care habits and
you do them every day might be past that
point for you and I my friend I think
you and I have have lost that battle
Yeah
James May I jump in for one second what
is a good way to phrase that so if
someone wants to have not a mission
statement but some type of
statement for this is the type of person
I want to be I think it's I'm the type
of person who blank for example so like
I'm the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts or I'm the type of person who
shows up on time or I'm the type of
person who finishes what they start
whatever aspect of your identity that
you're trying to reinforce that's kind
of the the story you can also phrase it
as a question so for example rather than
saying I'm the type of person who
doesn't miss workouts you could have
this question that's related to the
identity you want to build and you kind
of carry it around with you all day and
like in this example maybe the question
is what would a healthy person do and so
you're just kind of walking around all
day asking yourself you know what should
I get for lunch well what would a
healthy person do or should I take the
an Uber or should I walk to the next
meeting well what would a healthy person
do and you just kind of like go around
your day and try to make decisions that
you feel like support that identity but
I think you start with who is the type
of person I wish to become so let's say
I'm the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts and then the second step is
prove it to yourself with small wins so
which small actions what little habits
cast votes for being the kind of person
who doesn't miss workouts well maybe one
thing is
rather than doing a 45 minute workout
when I only have 10 minutes I reduce the
scope but stick to the schedule and I do
a couple Sprints or I do you know
five sets of push-ups or whatever it is
and so you find ways to
reinforce your desired identity even if
it's small especially in the beginning
because if you can show up consistently
if you kind of Master the art of showing
up and Performing these small habits you
build up this sense of momentum you kind
of start to reinforce and shape that new
identity and the more evidence that you
have for it
at some point you kind of cross this
invisible threshold where you're like oh
I guess I am that kind of person you
know like if you go out and shoot a
basketball for five minutes you don't
think oh I'm a basketball player but if
you do it every day for six months or a
year or two years like at some point you
cross this invisible line you're like
you know I guess playing basketball is
kind of part of who I am so I think
you're trying to accumulate
actions that support your desired
identity
so let's do a case study and we're going
to take a look at this is purely selfish
at email because you've been very
methodical and
executed very well with email
I also have the five bullet Friday which
has been going for God have not missed
it week in fact God knows how many years
it's been a long time it's pretty wild
it serves as sort of a diary for me too
I don't know if this is true for you but
looking back at these additions is
actually very fun for me because I get
to see like oh three and a half years
ago oh yeah that week oh wow I thought
that happened look at how dumb past Tim
was yeah there's present Tim is so much
smarter I've learned so much oh God yes
one cup Boy Can Dream a Boy Can Dream so
let's say one of my resolutions and this
is going to be a bit of a force fit but
not necessarily so like sure I am
someone who
prioritizes email above all the other
platforms and grows it consistently
and you may have some familiarity with
with my newsletter and how we do things
and I know you and I've had some
exchanges before sure what might be some
small wins or just changes that you
would make things you would add try test
anything at all so I like was browsing
your website a little bit before this
conversation
and I kind of feel like the main
difference also first of all I just need
to say you already have an enormous
email list so like to do some sort of
intervention on somebody who's got
millions of subscribers is like kind of
a ridiculous premise to start with but
I'll take the question seriously no no I
want to give credit where credit is due
I think you have more I think that
you're prioritizing
is better reflected in your actions and
decisions with respect to email than in
my case it's interesting you say that I
that was what I was about to say is I
feel like the only difference the only
primary difference is
you emphasize the podcast
as you're like number one and I
emphasize email as like my number one
yeah and something has to lead the day
now that you know of course this does
not mean that's a bad decision by you
right podcast is enormous and it
probably is the more important thing for
your business but each person needs to
decide what that is in my case if you go
to my website it's very clear like if
something is going to be the primary
call to action on the home page it's the
email list not the podcast or you know
whatever so
that's just a question that like you
need to have is like are we willing to
emphasize this more and if not then
that's a positive constraint you're
setting and you can decide okay given
that email is going to be number two to
the podcast how can we grow it more yeah
well you know you've raised such a
simple idea for me like right now if you
look at the homepage right it's podcast
up top on the banner and then you have
the email sign up which is sort of right
below that to the right and it could be
as simple as like all right well look
this doesn't have to be a forever
decision let's just swap those two try
it out for a period of time make the top
of the email the whole thing is email
everybody's biased to how their story
played out so I'm biased to say email is
the most important but my like my stance
on it is make the banner on your home
page the email list and then you can
email all the podcast episodes out to
these people yeah every time I think
about it sensibly
email is the most important because you
can share the podcast much more easily
via email then you can share the
newsletter via podcast because to share
you know via podcast requires task
switching almost I don't want to say
always but probably 90 of the time if I
had to just pull a number out of my ass
people are listening to a podcast as a
secondary activity
very
different Beast than someone who sits
down opens an email and clicks on links
they're opening an email explicitly in
the case of of Five Below Friday and and
perhaps also in the case of your email
to find things to learn and investigate
right it's an explicit
goal well this is kind of what you're
getting at but email is in a position
where it's both both of the assets are
very flexible you can talk about
whatever you want on a podcast and you
can write about whatever you want in an
email but email has the advantage of
having links that you can click on right
away and so it can be immediately acted
upon whereas as you mentioned often
people are listening to a podcast while
they're on a run or making dinner or in
a car and they're not in a position to
click on a link right then
and so even if you tell them give them a
great URL to go to it just the
conversion rate's not going to be nearly
as high because people are are busy and
then by the time they get home they
don't remember to do it and you know so
anyway yeah I for all those reasons I
like email more and honestly I kind of
feel like they're they're really only
two things that came to mind the first
is are you going to emphasize it more in
the web design so put it above the
banner at the top of the page or above
the fold
and then the second thing is
how are you
cross-pollinating between your different
assets so I mentioned Instagram for me
so that's a that's like of the top five
ways that we drive email subscribers
Instagram is one of them and the reason
is because a lot of the posts have Links
at the bottom that encourage people to
sign up for three two one or they
mention the newsletter in the caption
or a story that we post will have like
an actual Link in it that you can click
to sign up on the page and so are you
using asset your other assets like
Instagram or Twitter or the podcast to
drive email subscribers example for the
podcast would be I know for previous
episodes I don't know if you do this for
every episode but sometimes you'll
mention five bullet Friday at the end
what if we mentioned it at the beginning
of the show rather than the end of the
show more people are going to be
listening in the first minute than are
going to be listening in the 120th
minute so
it's really just about using the other
assets to cross-pollinate and to do it
at strategic points that are high
leverage yeah
I would rather make fewer asks but to do
it at the exact right moment
then to kind of like sprinkle calls to
action everywhere
so those are the two things that came to
mind
I want to share one of your questions if
that's okay this is from your newsletter
someone compiled your questions over two
years put them in a blog post of one of
them
let's see I have many highlighted
this is one that related to my
prioritization of email and as you
pointed out focusing on the podcast the
placement of the mention of Bible Friday
being at the end as opposed to the
beginning
and it is if someone could only see my
actions and not hear my words what would
they say are my priorities right that's
a good one it's a good one like yeah
don't tell me what's important just show
me your calendar pal yeah okay there we
go we all have stories that we tell
ourselves you know like it's very easy
for us to justify internally but if
you're just looking at how you're acting
what are you actually emphasizing yeah I
think we all have felt that pain at
various times which I should say these
aren't just questions I come up with for
like the readers like these are all
things I need to ask myself you know
like pretty much everything I write is
intended to to help me
get back to Center or to course correct
also to reinforce something you just
said the the more
success you have even if it's a small
amount
although I do think it tends to go
somewhat exponential at some point the
there may be exceptions to this but
among my friends and peer Group whatever
that might mean
uniformly I have seen the more success
you have whether it's a base hit or a
double or a home run or 10 home runs the
harder it becomes to focus
for a lot of people because
in the beginning stages of your career
or maybe mid-stages
you're choosing between
unattractive options and maybe one or
two attractive options you're trying to
generate attractive options they're like
not even there you're trying to create
them you know or find them or seek them
out exactly yeah once you go from having
one attractive option to two attractive
options on your menu
things really change dramatically and
then when that goes to 10 things
and then it goes to 10 interesting
people with 10 interesting things it
gets harder so it's and I'm not saying
this to
ask my audience to cry a river for me I
don't expect that you know woe is me
it's these are quality problems but you
really want to sharpen the acts of
asking these types of questions and
building these systems before you have
your first one or two base hits because
if you try to sharpen the ax when you
are getting
when you are feeling as though you are
just up to your neck and water kind of
floating down the Rapids it's going to
be very very hard so I'm just I would
just say well success generates not only
opportunities but also distractions and
so in a sense like success almost kind
of eats itself you know it's like
that you get good at something and so
then that brings new opportunities your
way some of them are novel or
interesting or different and so you do
those and then you turn around six
months later and you don't have any time
to do the thing that made you successful
in the first place so yeah you you gotta
be careful about what you say yes to
I'd like to ask you about two
goals slash habits slash behavioral
modifications that are of interest to me
personally and also I would imagine of
interest to other people listening and
I'm curious because you've had 10
million copies sold you've interacted
with or certainly observed a lot of your
readers people who have tested different
things from the book
let's start with well the two that come
to mind and I've actually I'm good at
the second but the two are cutting back
on caffeine and meditating right so the
meditating is an addition the cutting
back on Kathy and a lot of people would
think of as a subtraction
I would love to hear any thoughts you
might have on cutting back on caffeine
sure so if you want to break a bad habit
there are kind of three potential paths
you could take so the first is you can
eliminate it entirely so elimination
second option is you can reduce it so
you could like curtail it to the desired
degree I don't want to never drink
caffeine I just want to drink less of it
and the third option is you could
substitute it you could replace it with
a different habit and of those three
often times replacing it is actually the
more effective option so for example if
you get your caffeine from drinking Coke
or soda or something like that then
maybe you find out hey you know
something I really love from this
experience is I actually just like
drinking a carbonated beverage and so
it's the carbonation that I like and
maybe if I substitute it with sparkling
water or something like that I still get
the carbonation sensation but I don't
have the caffeine associated with it
anymore and so that's a way of
substituting for that behavior and you
still get something that the experience
provides this is actually kind of an
important just like larger picture big
picture thing about habits which is
every habit that you have we build
habits to solve the repeated problems
that we face in life and I'm using
problems in a very general sense here
you know like let's say that you come
home from work and you feel tired and
exhausted from a long day
well in a sense coming home from work at
6 pm and feeling tired is a problem and
especially if you experience it
repeatedly you got to come up with some
kind of solution for that and generally
speaking we just kind of like try things
out in life and so you can imagine one
person solves the problem of feeling
exhausted by scrolling Instagram
mindlessly for 30 minutes yeah and
another person solves that problem by
playing video games for an hour and a
third person solves it by going for a
run for you know 20 minutes and those
are all solutions to the same kind of
underlying problem but some of them are
more healthy or more productive or
service better than others and what do
you think the odds are that the
solutions you've come up with to the
repeated problems in your life are the
optimal one like it's just so unlikely
that whatever you happen to have
stumbled into throughout life is the
perfect way or the best habit that
serves you most so I think what I'm
trying to get out out there is maybe
take a little bit of the pressure off
yourself and don't worry about judging
yourself so much you're just trying to
solve the repeated problems that you
face but once you realize that it's
unlikely that your current Solutions are
the Optimal Solutions well now maybe we
can step outside and above ourselves and
look down and try to come up with a
better solution so rather than drinking
a Coke to get the carbonation we can
drink Sparkling Water so that's one
example for the substitution
if we want to take the other path of
reduction something I've noticed about
myself is
if I get a six pack of beer and I put it
in the the front of the fridge like in
the door or on a shelf that's like right
at eye level I'll drink one every night
just because it's there but if I take it
and put it on the lowest shelf in the
fridge and like it's kind of all the way
back in the corner I can't really see it
unless I'm bending down
it'll sit there for two weeks or three
weeks like and so I'm like did I want it
or not you know like if it was obvious
then I grabbed one but if it wasn't then
I avoid it and I think that's a simple
question to ask yourself where do I get
my caffeine is it coffee is it soda and
is that really obvious is it like the
coffee's sitting right out on the
counter is the the soda like the first
thing I see at eye level when I open the
fridge and how can I make it less
obvious
in atomic habits they're kind of what I
call the four laws of behavior change
and it's just this big picture view of
how to build a good habit and so if you
want to build a good habit you want to
make your habits obvious attractive easy
and satisfying and if you want to break
a bad habit you just do the opposite of
those four so you want to make it
invisible make it unattractive make it
difficult make it unsatisfying and so I
think how can you make coffee or soda
invisible how can you make it difficult
to drink like keep it outside of the
house Etc so there are a variety of
strategies you could use here you know
like let's say you live with a family
and other people are going to want to
drink it but you don't want to well
there's a there's this little kind of
diabolical tupperware container called
the kitchen safe and it has a lock box
code on the top of it and so you could
give the other family members the lock
box code but then they don't give it to
you and you just put the soda inside of
that and so it stays in that Tupperware
and you can't access it so finding ways
to increase friction or to make it
difficult or to make it less obvious
those are all ways to potentially
curtail
the the caffeine habit the Locking
Tupperware what is it called again it's
called the kitchen safe the kitchen's
safe there are a few variations of this
and I know a number of families who use
them for phones so they will have meal
time or evening time or whenever it is
and they'll put the phones in the safe
and sure that's where they sit until the
phone free time has expired I've had
readers use it for like late night
snacking like they'll you know like the
chips go in at 7 pm or they're just they
just stay in that Tupperware and it's
set it's set to lock from 7 PM to 7 A.M
and so they just you know they can't get
to them late night and then they go to
sleep I'm just imagining myself so I'll
give you a confession so I love brownies
and two days ago for the first time made
brownies and spice cider it's like a
whole Christmas celebration thing even
though it's not Christmas yet and I ate
all the brownies last night and I'm not
proud of this I'm not beating myself up
about it because I'm gonna you know I'm
working out it's it's fine it's not a
big deal but I'm just imagining if I put
the brownies into this locking container
and do you know what a bear bin is there
are these like a bear Contraptions that
you use for camping I'm just imagining
me like swatting this safe around
smashing It On The Ground trying to get
the brownies up anyway that's more for
my own gratification folks so thanks for
listening let's talk about positive and
you already alluded to the four
principles or laws or ingredients but
meditating sure I think for a lot of
folks meditating is in the air
they've heard about it on this podcast I
know I should do it I just don't yep you
know by the time I have my coffee and do
this and make the sandwiches for the
kids it's too late
how would you suggest people approach
saying meditating in the morning just to
use use that couple things to think
about here so again let me just run
through the the four laws real quick
just as a primer for this answer so if
you want to build a good habit roughly
speaking there are four things that you
can do you want to make it obvious you
want to make it attractive you want to
make it easy and you want to make it
satisfying so obvious attractive easy
satisfying now if you're sitting there
and you're thinking how can I get myself
to meditate more you can just turn those
into questions and you can say how can I
make the behavior more obvious how can I
make it more attractive how can I make
it easier how can I make it more
satisfying and you'll start to notice
different things that you could do so
for example how can I make meditation
more obvious well do you have a clear
space where you're going to do this you
know like maybe you need a meditation
pillow and it's in the corner of your
bedroom or it's in the corner of some
other room that is the dedicated
meditation space and this is exactly
where it happens so it's obvious where
the behavior is going to occur make it
attractive there are many different
types of meditation and there are a lot
of ways to get into it and this is true
for any habit by the way
for some reason I think we often choose
habits that we feel like we should do
but it's not necessarily the one that we
want to do individually and there's you
know there may not necessarily be a
thousand ways to do everything in life
but there's almost always more than one
way and you should choose the version
that you're most genuinely excited about
you know that is most appealing and
interesting to you because if you're
genuinely interested in it then even
like there's gonna be all kinds of ways
to improve you'll find all sorts of
things that you could like refine or
make it better but if you're not
actually interested if you're like not
genuinely engaged in the task even the
obvious stuff is going to feel like a
hassle you know it's gonna feel like a
chore even if it's straightforward so
do you want a guided meditation maybe
it'd be nice to have somebody kind of
walk you through it or do you want to
find a meditation that has like lovely
music associated with it do you not want
anything do you just want silence and
you want to be able to like hear
yourself think for a minute or listen to
your own breath for five minutes and
that's kind of the objective but what
sounds most attractive and appealing to
you try to find a version of The Habit
that you're actually interested in
this actually I think connects to the
timing piece that you were talking about
Tim which is yeah in the morning is a
great time for a lot of people but if
you have young kids and like your
four-year-old is running around you're
trying to figure out how to get pants on
them and you need to make you know
breakfast like that's probably not a
good time to do it you know so like find
a time and a space where that habit can
live where it's attractive and you're
not just going to end up frustrated
because you're trying to like swim
upstream make it easy so rather than
doing 15 or 20 minutes or 30 minutes of
meditation which hey that sounds great
because your favorite Guru does it but
listen like why not just do 60 seconds
because if you can Master the art of
showing up if you can just do it for a
minute and actually stick to that day in
and day out then you're starting to
build the habit and now you have
something you've like gained a foothold
and you can advance to the next level
one of the the things I recommend in the
book is called the two minute Rule and
it says just take whatever habit you're
trying to build and you scale it down to
someone takes two minutes or less to do
so read 30 books year becomes read one
page or meditate you know five days a
week for 30 minutes becomes meditate for
60 seconds and you're just trying to
master the art of showing up you know
like a habit must be established before
it can be be improved it's got to become
like the standard before you worry about
optimizing it into some perfect thing so
make it easy to do make it easy to show
up and then the final thing is make it
satisfying now if you've done those
first three steps well it's obvious it's
an attractive version of it it's pretty
easy to do you're probably going to feel
pretty good about yourself because
you're at the end of The Meditation
session now so like that'll probably be
pretty satisfying but you can layer on
some kind of additional benefit you know
maybe you get to have your favorite type
of coffee or your favorite drink after
that or maybe you get to have
a bubble bath or a walk in the woods or
whatever sounds motivating to you you
know so find some way to to add some
additional positive emotions to the
experience because if you feel good
about it you're going to want to repeat
it and this is something that in atomic
habits I call it the cardinal rule of
behavior change which is
behaviors that get rewarded get repeated
and behaviors that get punished get
avoided and it's so basic it's so
obvious but all humans want to feel good
you know we all want to have positive
emotions to be supported to be loved to
be rewarded to have something that feels
good and so how can you get that feeling
and Associate it with your habits that's
kind of the the core idea and ultimately
this connects back to what we talked
about with identity which is the perfect
version is when you perform a habit and
you feel good because it's reinforcing
your desired identity you know I'm the
type of person who wants to meditate
each day or I'm the type of person who
doesn't miss meditation sessions and
then even if it's only 60 seconds you
can feel good about doing it because
it's reinforcing your desired identity
so that's kind of a quick case study on
how to apply the ideas yeah totally as
you're speaking I'm thinking about all
these other questions and how you could
phrase the I'm the type of person who
looks forward to meditating right like
how do you make that a true statement
and it actually brought me back to San
Francisco many many many years ago
before I took my first meditation
training and so on and so forth
I began I haven't thought about this in
like a decade at least I began with
listening to I think it was we're gonna
Party Like It's 1999 by Prince one song
nice and in the morning I would just sit
down lean against the wall get in good
posture and just breathe deeply while
listening to Prince for one song that
was it and it made a difference it made
a difference because as you said I've
never thought of it in these terms but I
became accustomed to showing up
and Simply Having however small it might
have been it was small a tiny slot in my
mental calendar which was when I wake up
I'm going to sit down and do this thing
and then when I did Transcendental
Meditation training later and the
experimented with many different forms
of meditation since going from three
minutes to 20 minutes
was a dilation of the amount of time
required but it wasn't introducing an
entirely new species of calendar slot
right it was already there once you've
mastered the art of showing up scaling
it up increasing the scope is much
easier once you're already the kind of
person who's doing it every day you know
yeah and those are good examples I think
actually it may be I don't know if it's
your question to him or I feel like I've
heard you say it before but this idea of
what would this look like if it was easy
you know or what would it look like to
be the kind of person who looks forward
to writing or looks forward to
meditating or looks forward to working
out that's a it's a question worth
taking seriously because you can usually
design The Habit to feel like hey this
isn't a chore like this is something
like this is how I want to be spending
my days and that's really where you want
to get to because for a habit to last
it's got to be part of your normal
lifestyle it has to be something that
you know like you want to show up and do
this each day and so you're trying to
find the version of it that benefits you
the most yeah what would this look like
or what might this look like like if it
were easy as a question I ask myself all
the time and
I think part of the reason for that is
that I've
for most of my life prided myself on
having
High pain tolerance being able to do the
hard things in the service of the long
term and when you're starting out like
you said kind of clawing your way to any
good opportunity or any open window and
you're just kind of slipping back on the
mud slope of of establishing any type of
modicum of success you're opening
windows that are closed yeah exactly
like that was locked and you're like not
anymore clawing like a raccoon at the
window trying to figure out the lock and
at least for me I think I began to
associate results with
grinding or some degree of effort and so
the association would be if my effort
isn't above a certain threshold I am not
doing the thing that will produce an
optimal result but past a certain point
that can be a
false filter if that makes any sense so
I asked myself that constantly if I'm
recording a podcast right I've thought
just give an example I haven't done this
yet but I thought you know what the
technology is good enough why do I do
podcast at least as it stands right now
in a static position like why not figure
out get the best headset available
figure out connectivity and go for a
walk figure out a way to record a
podcast while I'm walking right I would
check off a number of these laws that
you mentioned microphone in one hand
starlink dish in the other you're just
gonna be yeah
fit right in in Austin you'll be like
the ultimate version of the guys like
sifting for gold on the beach like
you're gonna be oh yeah that would be
amazing yeah I just put the star link on
the back of my head mount it on top of
the headset yeah so let's use Atomic
happens as the case study sure how would
you deconstruct Atomic habits both in
its its writing but then also its launch
right because those are intertwined yeah
in what made it successful what were the
things that really
seemed to be the art community's levers
for producing to the extent that you can
right you're on one side of the tennis
net yeah so any examples this will
probably be a long answer because
there's a lot to talk about so let's
break it into a two categories writing
and marketing
so and also like the truth is the honest
answer might be like I don't know I got
lucky maybe that's the truth but I
suspect that there are things a lot of
things you can do to influence the
outcome and so I can I'll walk you
through what I tried to do so on the
writing side
I think you have to operate with this
Assumption of like let me create more
value that I'm going to capture
you try to produce a hit
the ultimate thing that drives Book
Sales is creating something that is
actually genuinely valuable to people
and it has to be so good that people
will talk about it Word of Mouth you
know Atomic habits has sold over 10
million copies at this point we could
argue I'd be interested to know what you
think the estimate is Tim but there's
some number of copies that you could
sell just by having an audience and a
good marketing plan and sheer force of
will and putting a lot of effort in
maybe it's 25 000 maybe it's a hundred
thousand I don't know it's at some point
there's some number where you can't get
beyond that even if you have a large
audience
just by the marketing energy it has to
be word of mouth and I think certainly
once you're in the millions or tens of
millions of copies like the only way a
book grows that much is people recommend
it and I like Seth godin's measure for
this which is says if you want Word of
Mouth you have to create something
remarkable and that means that it's
worthy of remark right that it's like
worthy of talking about and so you have
to start with that so like the three
things that I always focus on are am I
writing something that's Timeless so if
it's Timeless and Evergreen then you
have a longer period where it could
become a hit if it's something that's
just really relevant to the current
moment two years from now you've kind of
passed your window for it taking off
it's like the blog post you wrote that
got to the producers for television yes
right similar example right am I writing
something that's pretty Universal so
that's another a kind of filter for me
everybody has habits everybody's trying
to build good habits or break bad ones
even if they're not thinking about it
like carefully it's just kind of part of
life and so not everybody in the world
is going to buy the book but pretty much
anybody can look at the cover and be
like yeah I get why that would be useful
you know like that's that's a thing that
you know most people are going to want
so Timeless is a universal and then I
feel like you have to pick something
that fascinates you because if you're
genuinely interested in it that comes
through in the writing
you know like I think Morgan Hassell has
some kind of line where it's like
writing for yourself is fun and it shows
writing for other people is work and it
shows that's a good line people have a
good BS meter for that and like you need
to pick something you're genuinely
fascinated with quick side cell for
Morgan the psychology of money
the title may seem generic the book is
outstanding I really really enjoyed it
yeah Morgan's great okay so that's
that's kind of like my rights on the
time let's write something Universal
write something that fascinates you and
do all that with the intention of
creating something genuinely remarkable
or that creates value for people that
sounds those things sound good I think
it's worth asking like what does it look
like in practice to actually do that so
something let me just give you some
examples and I'm just going to keep
interrupting because because I've had
too much caffeine I'm going to blame it
on caffeine
I would also love to at some point so
you're going to give some examples I
would love to know how you thought about
modeling other books or or constructing
the format and layout of your book yeah
not the visual layout per se no I know
what you mean structuring the book
because I've seen many examples of you
deconstructing
sentences quotes yeah
application essays we probably won't get
to that but we went to Switzerland right
you're very good at modeling
so at some point I'd love for you to
speak to that yeah I think you should
you should deconstruct the cool things
that you see in life you know like when
you come across something that you
really like or that you think's cool so
in my case like I was writing a book so
how do I deconstruct bestsellers like
what's going what's going on there and
if you find a single example of
something it doesn't really tell you
anything but if you start to find
patterns then that's probably something
to pay attention to so I think actually
this is a great segue to kind of some of
these examples I was going to give so
let's say when I was riding Atomic
habits early on I was like how I know
what I'm trying to achieve I'm trying to
write the most comprehensive and most
useful book that's ever been written on
habits now I have no idea if I achieve
that and it's not really for me to
decide if we're being honest like I
don't get to choose that it did that
it's that's up to the readers to decide
is that a Mark that you hit or not but I
think that has to be the target you got
to start there otherwise you're you're
never just gonna stumble into that
outcome you know so like you have to
like try to intend to create something
great
so how do we do that I looked at a bunch
of books not just about habits but also
other bestsellers one of the first
things I did was I went to the table of
contents for all those books and then I
was like how are these books arranged
and what you'll find is that
a lot of best-selling books they have
three they they break things into thirds
or it doesn't always have to be thirds
but they have like a clear structure
that the book goes through so that you
can look at the table of contents and
even though you don't know what's in the
chapters you know exactly where you're
headed as a reader what people don't
want is they don't want to open up a
book and feel lost feel like I have no
idea where this guy's gonna go with this
and it kind of feels like they're
wasting their time so a couple examples
you could do and I thought about these
but I didn't actually use these for
Atomic habits I could have had a table
of contents that was like habits of the
past habits of the present habits of the
future you know pretty clearly like
where that book's gonna go if you see
those categories in the table of
contents or
Power of Habit is another example if you
look at the table of contents there I
think he does habits of individuals
habits of businesses and then habits of
societies so it's like individuals
organizations societies you can see how
he's kind of moving up the hierarchy as
you go through the book and another one
that I looked at I can't remember which
one of Cal newport's books it was but it
was either deep work or something like
that but he kind of like he had a
section on here are the the rules that
you need to follow and then there were
you know four rules or six rules and so
each one of those got their section in
the book and the point is just there
needs to be a clear road map for the
reader and if you start looking through
what other bestsellers are doing you can
start to think about how to transport
that onto your own experience
another thing I did was I tried to look
at what is the average chapter length
for a lot of these books you know when I
signed the book deal
the publisher and the editors I was
working with which I love my publishing
team by the way but they were kind of
encouraging me to write longer chapters
like six thousand or eight thousand
words and I was coming at this as like a
blogger you know like most of the things
I wrote were like 2 000 words or 1500
words and eventually what I settled on
was most of the chapters were between
two and three thousand words and that
felt like the right length you know yeah
and just for folks to have a reference
point I mean one printed page what would
you say it's roughly like 300 yeah I
think most of my chapters were about 10
pages so yeah
so 300 words yeah if it's a 3000 word
chapter maybe it's 10 or 12 Pages
something like that
so yeah figuring out the length and I
started to notice other things that like
novels would do or
books that weren't necessarily
non-fiction
they the chapters are really short and
there's kind of this momentum that gets
into it like it kind of gets you
flipping pages and it's easier to keep
churning through the chapters and so I
wanted to have that kind of chapter
length
I actually think Atomic habits is still
a little bit longer than I was hoping I
just couldn't figure out a compress it
more my initial manuscript for the book
was 700 it was like 712 Pages or
something
and the finished version of the book is
like 250 so you know yeah I compressed
it by you know 66 or whatever so it's
it's much smaller than it started out as
which I think is good because I feel
like a lot of books especially business
books they could have been like a blog
post or a 20-page paper and they'd get
turned into a 200 Page book so I wanted
to do the opposite I [ __ ] hate that
it's the worst it's so bad but I
actually think if you look at books that
sell really well a lot of the time
they're like 180 to 220 Pages they're
they're actually a little bit even a
little bit shorter than what I ended up
hitting so these are all examples of
deconstructing you know best sellers of
what's going on probably the most
important place to do this is with
titles so I have a spreadsheet of
hundreds of titles for books that I the
way that I did it was I said I'm only
going to look at books that have sold a
million copies or more that's what I'm
trying to achieve so let me just see how
many books I can find that have done
that
and quick question tactical question did
you do that through
access to Nielsen book scan
asking a publisher for help with
Publishers Marketplace I didn't have
access to book scan because I was just a
I was just a poor blogger who was you
know trying to make a book so I didn't
have access to any of that stuff
but what I did was I just did tons of
Google searches yeah and usually what
happens is that when an author hits a
million copies or four million or
whatever yeah yeah they'll let you know
yeah they let you know and so there's
all kinds of stuff or you'll find like
if you just search a title and then copy
sold
there's New York Times articles that
profile an author and they say you know
the book sold six million copies or
whatever so it was just a bunch of leg
work like that
anyway I put together that spreadsheet
let's say I got like 150 titles or
something and then I started to look for
patterns so what format do all these
titles follow and I think I ended up
coming up with they're about six I won't
be able to remember them all off the top
of my head but the most common format is
the blank of blank so the Power of Habit
the life-changing magic of tidying up
The Power of Now the power of positive
thinking
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] the
blah blah so it's always the blank of
blank and that's a very proven the war
of art it's a very proven format and the
psychology of money like we just keep
going on and on and on there's so many
examples like that and usually what
people do is they take their topic and
that's the second piece and then they
take some type of descriptor and that's
the first one and ideally you're
combining things that are not usually
combined so
like
the life-changing magic of tidying up so
tidying up is the topic of the book but
now you're telling me that it's
life-changing and what you find is a lot
of these best-selling books they have
some element of contrast in the title
there's something that's unexpected
about it so even the another common
format is you just take and this is of
not giving a [ __ ] right you don't
usually exactly like yeah the f word is
actually the least subtle thing right so
like there's this interesting contrast
between the two another common format
this is the one that I use for Atomic
habits is you take the topic of your
book and then you layer on some kind of
unexpected descriptor before it so
I'll get to Atomic habits in a second
but like extreme ownership by Jocko so
the idea is you take ownership and
responsibility for your life but you do
it like in this extreme way it's not
just like a regular idea of taking
ownership or Cal Newport deep work
you're doing work but it's a special
kind of work it's not the normal type of
thing that you're thinking about so
these are these are just examples there
there are a couple more patterns that I
found but and then ultimately you got to
decide like which one makes the most
sense for me you know which one feels
like it's the best fit for my book but I
started to generate a bunch of titles
and which one can you live with forever
yes the titles are really tricky because
they need to pass a lot of filters they
they need to be about like they need to
cover what the book is actually about so
like in my case it needed to actually
talk about habits I think it's important
to have some element of contrast so like
in my case Atomic has multiple meanings
it can be tiny or small so your habit
should be easy to do it can be the
fundamental unit in a larger system so
like atoms built into molecules and you
know systems versus goals is like a big
part of the book
it can be the source of immense energy
or power so I think if you kind of
combine all those three meanings you get
the the under the like Big Arc of the
book which is you make changes that are
small and easy to do you layer them on
top of each other like units in a larger
system and then you end up with these
kind of powerful or remarkable results
as a as a byproduct so for all of those
reasons I kind of felt like atomic was a
great word to describe it
but it needs to so it needs to describe
what the topic is it needs to be
interesting and compelling or like a
little bit different sometimes good
habits are like a little bit weird in a
sense like nobody was really using the
phrase Atomic habits before the book
came out you know it wasn't like a way
that you would describe a habit you
might describe it as small but you
wouldn't describe it as like Atomic it
had been good habits
I just for people out there right you're
going to be competing with the entire
internet yes for search results I
actually think a lot of titles fall into
this Pitfall which is they use a phrase
that is commonly used and you want a
phrase that you can like own in the
reader's mind
you know like you don't want to be
competing with yeah all the other things
that use the phrase good habits
you know four hour work week is a good
example of this nobody really used that
phrase before the book it was like a
little bit weird yeah in the sense that
it wasn't part of normal conversation
and that allowed you to own it
it also had that element of contrast
you're like man I work for 40 hours a
week you're telling me I can work for
four you know it's like it's the
surprising thing another example that
might be like Rich Dad Poor Dad you know
so that book has a great time of
contrast between the between the two
so
it needs to be like something that you
actually want and needs to cover the
topic of the book it needs to have this
element of contrast like there's there's
a lot of filters for it to pass and
that's why coming up with good titles is
hard yeah let me add one thing too
because there may be some I have a lot
of Engineers and computer scientists and
so on we listen to this podcast if if
you guys are starting to develop hives
because this sounds like oh my God this
is marketing I hate marketers all
marketing Liars
I'd like to emphasize that if you want
anything I shouldn't say anything if you
want a book you write to be remarkable
there are some prerequisites
in other words what are the antecedents
to something the being or becoming
remarkable one of them is
it needs to be remembered people can't
remember the title it's very hard to
remarkable upon it in any way that is
Meaningful and this also translates and
applies to the table of contents right
so in the four hour work week I had this
d-e-a-l structure and I thought very
very intently about how to structure the
book but then also how to label the
different structures and I had multiple
options that could have worked if you
have the book in your hand almost all of
them could have worked but if I want
someone to be able to remember
apply and also talk about which requires
recall the elements in the book having
something that is an acronym d-e-a-l
that is easy to remember
was I think a critical ingredient it's
to your point given how many things are
outside of your control not sufficient
to guarantee in any way that something
will hit the bestseller list but
necessary so necessary but not
sufficient I think
what were some of the
critical decisions or
I suppose critical decisions is is most
interesting to me but it could also be
lucky happenings that you set the
conditions for if that makes any sense
first of all the launch of atomic habits
I started planning it about 15 months
ahead of time so it was about it was
like a 15 month process
that doesn't mean it has to be that long
I think you could still do an excellent
launch in nine months Maybe
but you're going to need a lot of time
like sometimes I'll hear from authors
and they'll be like hey my book's coming
out in two months like you know what
should I do and I still think there are
plenty of things to do but in a sense
you're kind of like you're already like
a year behind you know so it's a long
process and to take it that seriously
it's not like an accident when you see a
lot of these books doing that like
people are spending a lot of time on it
so
that's the first thing is you need to
take it seriously and give it enough
time so what do you do with that year
well
we didn't really do much different like
there's not many things that I did that
you like have never heard of an author
doing before but we did them at a larger
scale than most people would have done
so let's take podcasts for example doing
a podcast tour for your book is a very
popular typical thing to do when your
book comes out
we put together a list so I went through
iTunes and I clicked on every category
of shows
that we felt like could be relevant to
the book so Health and Fitness business
you know etc for each of those
categories I think usually iTunes lists
like 100 shows or so in each category so
we went through all the hundred for each
of those categories and then we
identified every show that was already
an interview show so I wasn't trying to
convince anybody to bring me on that
wasn't already talking to people then
put all those shows in a spreadsheet I
think we ended up with like maybe 300.
and then I wrote individual emails to
all 300 hosts so that takes a long time
you know now we had like kind of a
general template but I would customize
each one and there was a section in each
email where I would say hey you've had
on this previous guest you know in this
episode or you talked about this topic
in this episode I feel like I could you
know provide something new or expand on
that it seems like it already went over
well with your audience if you're
interested I'd love to come on you know
I'm sure I'm sure the show is going to
be successful whether I come on or not
but if you're interested you know let me
know and I feel like we could have a
good conversation
and you got to send 300 of those emails
for 100 of them to work out and so I I
wrote the drafts up and then I think
about three to four months before the
book came out it was about four months
we started sending them all out and
getting interviews scheduled I spent
like a two-month span before the book
came out recording as many as I could
and I ended up getting about 75
interviews recorded before launch week
we asked everybody to release during
launch week now not everybody did but
pretty much everyone at least would
either do that week or like one of the
weeks before or after
and this is one of my core principles
for the launch which is you want a
concentrated strike you want to have as
much energy as possible in like a tight
window and the idea which Tim you know
this better than almost anybody
the idea is to make it seem bigger than
it actually is you know you want to feel
like it's everywhere and so I had 75
interviews hit during launch week I did
an additional 25 during the month that
the book came out so by the time we the
book was out for one month I had 100
interviews that had hit within that same
month span
so you've got a lot of action going on
there
at this point by the time the book came
out my email list was around 400 450 000
subscribers somewhere around there so I
have my own energy that I was trying to
provide so we sent a sample chapter
we sent the first chapter of the book
out I sent a couple excerpts during
launch week I had that segment that I
did on CBS This Morning during on launch
day and we sent that out so there were
probably four or five emails that were
coming out around that time
similar to what you did with
for our body and so on I did like a
series of bonuses so if you bought the
book during launch week I think there
was like a private webinar with me where
you could ask any question if you bought
three copies you got some extra PDF
downloads and a secret chapter if you
got 10 copies you got something else the
I think I only had three categories one
copy three copies and ten
and I did have one additional higher
tier it was like if you buy 500 books or
a thousand books or something like that
I would come and give a keynote and I
would not do that one again
I ended up giving a keynote in Malaysia
and a keynote in Australia just because
yeah yeah so
there were some smart people out there
internationally who were like this is a
great deal for us anyway but it was fun
it was all part of the launch and so I
did the bonuses I did the emails to my
audience we did the podcast push and all
of that action is happening more or less
in the same two-week window but
definitely in the same like one month
window so we've got all this kind of
energy happening
we also sent out influencer copies or
you know whatever you want to call that
advanced copies to people I didn't want
to send any galleys to anybody I only
wanted to send a finished copy because I
wanted their experience to be like the
actual finished book I wanted to be as
good as possible how did you compile the
list of advanced folks again the same
way with like the podcast I only wanted
to do it with people who opted in I'm
not trying to spam people with the book
so yeah again this takes a lot of effort
like we had to come up with a list of
people who we thought would be a good
fit and then we sent them all messages
and said hey I got this book coming out
would you be interested if so what's the
best address to send it to how did you
find those people sorry to be a pain in
the ass no no no it's it's a good
question who's a good fit yep the
obvious answer the one that everybody
thinks of is oh it's people with a big
audience who are interested in the topic
that I'm writing about but I actually
think you can do much better than that
which is we made a list so again what
are we trying to do here we're trying to
give the book a push and help it
generate Word of Mouth
so I think one thing that you could do
is say which communities already have a
lot of Word of Mouth like what are the
type of things that people are
interested in that they just can't shut
up about and so I came up with a list of
things crossfitters vegans
bullet journals like parenting and Mommy
blogs like I came up with a bunch of
categories of people who they love to
talk about their thing
and so I think I ended up having like 15
categories or so that's brilliant so
brilliant so now James can I pause for
one second there's a restaurant here in
Austin called I think it's El Arroyo and
they're famous for their signs that they
put outside and they have these really
pithy sayings and these these have
become books now mugs everything because
they're so clever and one of them was if
someone does CrossFit and is vegan which
do they talk about first
of course I thought was pretty good so
continue it's a worthwhile question
though you know you're like there there
are things that people get genuinely
excited about and love to talk to other
people that are in that industry about
and so are interested in that thing so
let's come up with a list of those and I
think I had like 15 or so
and then I went through those 15 and I
started asking okay which of these
communities is the book a good fit for
which where do I feel like there's
overlap so then so then I came up with a
subset that I don't remember what it was
but let's say it was like five or
something
and crossfitters were one of them as an
example and so I think one of the first
sets that we did was we said let's try
to find all the big crossfitters on
Instagram and then I think the the first
kind of batch that we sent out we did
like 30 crossfitters we did like 30
Venture capitalists and we did like 30
parenting and Mommy blogs right why
Venture capitalists that stands out from
the others there was a lot in the book
about growth getting one percent better
each day continuous improvement process
and business habits building a
successful company I am often asked to
speak at companies or to speak to sales
teams about those types of things so all
of that focus on systems and continuous
Improvement we felt like it overlapped
well with business and Venture
capitalists are seeing lots of
businesses and they're kind of the kind
of modern version of venture capitalists
a lot of them have like public presence
on Twitter or like they've got their own
podcasts or whatever so it was the kind
of thing where we felt like the topic
overlapped and they had an audience that
they could talk to to let me dig a
little bit on this because I'm I'm
fishing and it may be a Fool's errand
but sure I can kind of illustrate
something even if it doesn't apply to
you were you sending them to the Venture
capitalists
in part because
if you had
say endorsement or broadcast in some
fashion to their audiences maybe it
wouldn't result in a lot of copies sold
but if one of your income streams
is speaking to businesses and so on that
it could bolster that side
of things that might be true that was
definitely not what I was thinking when
I was doing the launch it might be true
it might be a good idea maybe I should
have been thinking about it but all I
was thinking about the launch was
where are my potential readers hanging
out and how can I get in front of them
or make that make it known to them that
this book exists and they would probably
enjoy it and again this all kind of goes
back to this feeling of this
concentrated strike or having to not
wanting to have a lot of energy in a
small window so we sent out those
influencer copies what ended up
happening is that the the crossfitters
were the best fit
and I think part of the reason is
venture capitalist for example I don't
even know how many like they all opted
in so I only sent them to people that
said they wanted to copy like I messaged
Sam hinke for example and he was like
yeah I would love a copy so that I sent
you know send him one or whatever so it
was that kind of thing
but they just didn't talk about it as
much or maybe it was they had a lot on
their plate and they didn't read it
right away whatever the reason was
the crossfitters did best and I think
they it was kind of interesting to them
I feel like if you're a crossfitter and
you have like a million followers on
Instagram you're probably sent a lot of
workout gear a lot of supplements a lot
of like stuff like that but you're very
rarely sent a book and it was like oh
this is kind of cool like this is a
topic that will help me in my training
and I don't usually get this and so they
opened it up and a lot of them took a
picture and then shared it on Instagram
and I we didn't ask for any of that by
the way we just asked people who opted
in and then we tried to get them a book
that we felt like was a great fit for
what they they were already interested
in and
what ended up happening is I've got all
these podcasts sitting I have the emails
going out I got the CBS segment and then
like 20 of the top crossfitters all
posted about it on their story within
the same like two week span now if
you're in into CrossFit and you follow
the top crossfitters on Instagram
surround sound that means everyone is
seeing this book right and you're like
man everybody I know is reading this
right now and that's not true at all but
it feels like it in your little Universe
right and so again it's like how can you
make it feel like it's everywhere for
that window of time
and so once we figured out that it
worked well for crossfitters then we
started saying okay let's Branch out in
Fitness so then we send it to a bunch of
bodybuilders a bunch of power lifters
you know and so on and it has turned out
that it's been a really great fit for
people in Fitness and they love the book
and they recommend it to their clients
and they find it useful for their own
training and so on and so we had to try
a variety of things for that to work out
I actually do think it's one that a lot
of venture capitalists like now and
recommend but it just was a slower burn
with them it didn't it didn't work
during the the influencer push as much
so anyway you get the idea none of those
strategies are radical or new you know
everybody's familiar with that if you're
looking up how should I launch a book
but what's different is we tried to do
it all at the same time and we tried to
do it all at a larger scale than most
people were doing so at first we only
sent 100 influencer copies but over time
we've sent a thousand well you're also
very surgical in where you chose
to go an inch wide and a mile deep where
I think a lot of folks who I
observe launching books they kind of
half-ass two dozen things
yeah and I mean that sounds too
pejorative maybe but
they really try to scatter
sprinkle effort across a ton of
different things and I have I've never
seen that work well
and if we're trying to quantify it right
let's just say one of your goals is to
be on the best seller list that could be
the Wall Street Journal which at least
last I checked is a truer best seller
list it's compiled based on Nielsen book
scan and other metrics the New York
Times list has sales input but it's
largely a sort of a editor's choice list
yeah it doesn't really track I actually
think I think the best one is Amazon
because the Amazon charts are the only
source that compiles print ebook and
audio into a single number now they
don't have every book sale right they're
only counting what's on Amazon but
that's I don't know eighty percent
ninety percent books yeah probably it's
95 of audio books audibles like
basically the only the way the people
listen audiobooks and it's most ebooks
too because Kindle's the way that most
people listen to or read ebooks so I
think it's probably the truest number of
what books are actually selling best is
the most sold list on Amazon it is the
truest however just like your morning TV
show The New York Times just as a
specific list has a mind share that
these other best-selling lists does not
have well what did we put on the cover
of atomic habits we put number one New
York Times bestseller not number one on
the Amazon charts you know isn't that
interesting like it's it's the truest
number but it doesn't have the branding
yep so if you want to hit that list at
least last I checked depends on the
category and so on but
you really want to have let's just say
the possibility of selling
again depending on your week and I would
suggest people do research and choose a
soft week if you're competing in this
way that's that's what I did with four
hour work week just as a side note you
can study these things it's like maybe
you should if you have a cookbook maybe
you shouldn't come out
right before
Thanksgiving and Christmas like you're
going to be fighting monsters if you try
to do that so pick your timing but if
you have to sell let's just call it or
have a chance of selling 20 000 copies
for two consecutive weeks
if you could only choose
one way to do that one medium
pests email fill in the blank which
would you choose okay and then if you
had the ability to add on a second which
would you choose if you had to
if you had to shake your entire launch
strategy around that then what would you
do right yeah I think it's just a
thought exercise that is worth doing so
that you do not succumb to the
distraction and well-meaning advice of
many people who will say you have to be
on this you have to be on this you must
do this this this this this this and
before you know it you're going to have
a must-do list of 20 different things
many of which are mutually exclusive if
you're trying to be excellent in any one
of those Yeah question for you what do
you think would have happened had you
not had your email list or instead of it
being 450 000 people at the time and it
had been 4 500 people
yeah I mean it's a good question there's
obviously there's no way to know but it
made an enormous difference and it in my
personal story
it's the only reason that the book
happened to begin with because I was
just a lowly blogger I have no
credentials you know like I'm not I
don't work for the New York Times I
don't teach at Harvard like I you know
they the Publishers in New York would
probably tell you oh we were looking for
a book on habits and we really like his
writing and stuff but the truth is they
would have never let me in the room if I
didn't have an email list of hundreds of
thousands of people you know like that
that's the thing that got me in the door
so
this is one of the things that I love
about writing which is
competence matters more than credentials
you know anybody can write on any topic
and that is a good thing and a bad thing
like the bad thing is that means you
need to be careful about what you read
because people can just make stuff up
and write whatever they want but the
good part is competence is what matters
you don't need permission from anybody
what you need is to write something
exceptional you need to write something
that genuinely makes a difference and is
useful in people's lives and if you
genuinely deliver on the problem that
you're writing about then you're in a
good position to make a career out of it
so anyway that wasn't a direct answer to
your question but I think the email list
was an enormous important part of it it
got the book deal to begin with and it
also really moved the needle on book
sales during launch week the little
hypothetical you threw out a minute ago
if you could only do one thing if I had
to choose one thing I'd choose email now
you know I have two million email
subscribers so that's maybe that's kind
of an obvious choice but even if it was
smaller I would spend time building the
audience and building the email list
because it does so many things that are
helpful like as you're building the list
you're as you're as you're writing each
week you're refining your ideas you're
learning what resonates with people
you're figuring out what your best
concepts are and all of that can inform
writing a better book which puts you in
a better position
and then you're also building the
audience along the way and so now you
have you know people that you can launch
to if I had to pick one thing that like
let's say your book's coming out you
know in five months and you don't have
an email list but you have a book that's
written what would I do then I would
focus externally and I would probably
just try to do as many podcasts as
possible and use your current advantages
to achieve and gain new advantages so
right now your main advantage is time
you got five months how are you gonna
spend it and then if you can knock it
out of the park with one podcast now you
have a really good episode maybe you can
get that published right away and you
can send it to some other shows that are
like not one level up and prove that
you're worthy to come on as a guest then
you try to knock those out of the park
and then if you have a really good one
you use that and send it to the next
level up and so on and you just kind of
try to keep going like that
so I do email first but if I didn't have
an email list I think I'd pick podcast
how many
Instagram followers would it take
if any for you to give up your email
list so let's say yeah so 10 million
20 million what would the minimal
compelling number be if there is one I
don't think I would do it it would have
to be over 100 million
I don't think I I don't know that I
would do it say more
I'm not in control of it so you know
like Instagram can be the algorithm can
change my account could get you know
suspended they could whatever there's
like you know I don't write about
provocative stuff but you get the idea
like I'm not in control
I could if you had a hundred million
followers I mean you also I'm assuming
some level of Engagement here right like
it's not just like Phantom followers
like you're assuming that you've got an
Engaged audience either way but I mean
like if Kim Kardashian were like I want
you to co-host yeah yeah she's like I'll
give you all my Instagram followers you
give me all your email lists yeah right
we'll do like makeup and yeah like booty
fitting dresses
right you get every Wednesday my next
book is booty habits it's like yeah I
yeah itself not just saying I'm telling
you that sounds like a bestseller more
squats but that's okay
yeah I don't know I mean there's there's
obviously some number where it'd be
stupid not to do it but
I don't know email's just so flexible
and how you can use it and Instagram is
like pretty constrained it's got to be
an image and I'm not a very you know I
don't post images of myself I don't I
don't know I'm in a similar boat if
somebody said I'll give you 50 million I
wouldn't trade I wouldn't do it for 50
million dollars I'll give uh just a tip
for folks also this is what I did with
the first book and pretty much every
book since if I'm sending out Advanced
copies I will send out galleys in some
cases at least with the earlier books I
did
because it allowed me to just have a
longer lead time I have very long books
as many people know they're they violate
every rule of length they tend to be
gigantic and it takes a while for people
to
explore these books so I will send out
galleys usually they're pretty much in
final form maybe there are a few
citations No appendix probably no page
numbers in the table of contents because
that stuff is moving around but
otherwise they're pretty solid they will
not have a final cover as an example but
what I will do if I'm sending out
Advanced copies whether they're galleys
or actual final product is and this is
very old-fashioned and it takes time but
I feel like if people skip some of these
time consuming steps on the front end
they are sacrificing a lot of long-term
potential because they may not ever
reach that escape velocity
get some Post-it notes and pick specific
chapters or sections so that you can say
if you don't have time to read the whole
book and I don't expect you to read the
whole book I tabbed the chapter that I
think is going to be most interesting to
you or that might be most interesting to
you which requires you to do some
homework like you did when you were
sending pitches to these podcasts you
had so and so on you talked about a b
and c it's like your audience really
responded well to X
why don't we do a b and c or would you
be opened if you'd be open to a b and c
and that due diligence pays incredible
dividends and what you did with podcasts
was exactly what I did for bloggers
for the four hour work week I had micro
serialized so I could offer different
blogs different places like Lifehacker
and so on exclusives on a particular
facet of the book and that required an
incredible amount of research on the
front end
it's worth it I I did the same thing for
the sending out the advanced copies I
can remember sending a message to Naval
and saying hey you know I know you're
super busy I do genuinely think you'll
find the book interesting if you only
have time to read three pages I think
these are the three to read yeah and I
have no idea if you read it or not but
he was like thanks you know I got it and
so you know that was it and you just it
takes a long time to do it in that way
but actually writing real emails to the
podcasters and not just doing a template
and actually selecting the pages that
you think will be most useful for each
Advanced copy and
not just spray and pray you know like
that that stuff is
it helps it actually works yeah you know
and also if you're being
very deliberate and very
thoughtful about how you are picking
these recipients
it oftentimes only takes one or two yeah
right so doing that diligence and
research on the front end increases the
likelihood of you at least having one or
two hits I actually think the word that
you just used which is thoughtful that's
the word that I come back to again and
again and that I hope I actually hope
that's the primary lesson that people
take away from this portion of the
conversation talking about writing
Atomic habits and talking about
deconstructing the marketing of it and
the launch of it
I I don't know maybe some people be like
oh this sounds like a lot of marketing
or whatever but I don't think about it
that way at all but I hope what comes
through is that what I'm trying is that
at each level of this experience the
research of the product the creation of
the book The launch and the marketing of
the book I'm trying to be as thoughtful
as possible you know to create the most
compelling or most useful version of the
book to share the best examples in the
book to find and identify the people who
will be the best fit for the book and to
deliver it to them in a way that is the
most thoughtful and makes it as easy as
possible for them to consume the book
and share it with others and if you're
thoughtful at each stage of that process
you're just going to end up with such a
better outcome and if you are just
trying to like
write a book but get it out there
quickly because you want to have a book
you don't want to write a book or if
you're just trying to Market it and get
it to as many people as possible because
you want to have a popular book you
don't really care about who it is that
it resonates with I mean if you cut
Corners like that then it's just really
hard to have a great outcome but if
you're thoughtful at each stage then it
tends to work out much better
yeah 100 agreed
coming back to the
Frameworks and principles in
Atomic habits are there any sections
chapters principles anything that you
wish more people paid attention to right
there's something that you put in
that gets glossed over or maybe who
doesn't stick
for whatever reason as much as other
things but you think it or these things
are important I mean I certainly have
examples from from my books from like
[ __ ] like I don't know if I made a
mistake in the way I presented that but
it's it's not getting its Fair Shake in
the sense of its importance well
sometimes you might just be like maybe I
thought that idea was better than it
actually was you know there might be
that too there might be that yeah I have
a couple so there are two things that
came to mind the first one is there's a
little example I give in the book about
maybe about halfway through or 40
through where I talk about having a
pregame routine and kind of doing things
in the same sequence each time in the
same Order each time and that helps get
you in the mindset and kind of initiate
the Habit so I you know I played
baseball through college and I have the
same pregame routine that I did before
each game and that kind of like flips
this switch in your mind where it's like
hey like it's time to compete now you
know like it's game mode
or the example I gave in the book
was this guy who he would do his writing
at the library and he would go to the
library sit at the same desk each day
and put on his headphones and play the
same playlist and that that little
sequence was a pregame routine that got
him in the mindset to do his writing
habit and one day he turned around and
realized that no music was playing he
just had his headphones on and it was
just it was just silent but he was
writing and he was like 20 minutes into
writing before he realized it and it's a
good example of how like just that
sequence of doing it the same way each
time and having that same pregame
routine that little ritual got him in
the mindset he didn't even need to press
play that day he was just ready to write
and so if you can come up with what that
little pregame ritual is for you that
can be a great way to initiate a habit
and I don't usually see people talk
about that I think actually I've heard
some examples like this on on your
podcast previously Tim like I think when
you talk to Josh waitskin at one point
he at some sometime he gave this example
maybe was in his books maybe it was a
conversation with you where he was
competing in this national competition
martial arts and he was told that he was
going to compete at one time and they
came up to him and he was like sleeping
or laying on a on a bench and they were
like hey sorry timing was wrong you're
actually up in like six minutes and he
was like normally I would have been
thrown off but he had this little
pregame ritual that he did and he tried
to as he developed it over time it
started out maybe it was 10 minutes and
then he tried to compress it so it was
seven minutes and then it was three
minutes and then eventually got it down
to where his little ritual was just
something he did for like 30 seconds so
they woke him up on that bench and he's
got to compete six minutes later but all
he needed was 30 seconds to kind of like
get in the right frame of mind and he's
like okay now I'm ready to go and so
those pregame rituals can be really
powerful if you make it your own and
come up with something that like you do
every time and it helps get you into the
mindset to compete or to perform
yeah for sure Josh
has given could be his personal example
he's also talked about Marcelo Garcia
whose nine-time world champion Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu arguably Maybe
uncontroversially probably one of the
best if not the best who's ever competed
in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu who who has a
similar ability to throw a switch
minutes before he'll compete in a world
championship about and it applies
furthermore
to most writers who I have had on the
podcast will have some type of
boot up sequence much like this person
who went to the library and people can
take solace in the fact there's no
consensus
there's no consensus it's very personal
I think you need to make it your own you
know yeah and there are also people who
will say like yeah I just dick around
for the first two hours I get literally
but that's not wasted time because it
takes that long for me to just like
Scribble or complain about my day on the
page so that I'm filling the page with
something and then it turns into
an hour later some paragraph that is the
Nugget of the beginning of what I need
to work on that day so it's not
eventually the pain of not doing it
becomes greater than the pain of doing
it and yeah yeah right or Neil game and
he's like yeah I'd go to the cabin and
I'm
I don't have to write but I'm not
allowed to do anything else
I love that that's great yeah and PJ
Novak also has his own approach who's
done a lot of a ton of television and
film work
and for me like right now you know
working on fiction for the first time
over the last let's call it six months
finding the routine like how I make the
coffee when I sit down the exact
sequence how I set up my laptop on the
laptop stand I mean it's very yeah
bunkish but it does make a big
difference so that was one the pre-game
sequence yes developing a pregame ritual
that works for you and then the other
one that I feel like this is something
that
if I had to pick a topic that I feel
like is more important than I realized
when I was writing the book I would
probably say this and that's the power
of the social environment
you know we are all part of multiple
tribes sometimes those tribes are like
large like what it means to be American
and sometimes they're they're small like
what it means to be a neighbor on your
street or a member of the local gym but
all of those tribes that you belong to
the large groups and the small groups
they all have this set of expectations
they've got a set of social norms for
what you do when you're in that group
and what the typical way is to act and
behave and what kind of habits they
follow and
the more that your habits go with the
grain of the expectations of the group
The more attractive they feel like to
you because it's like hey I fit in I
belong I'm part of something
and the more that they go against the
grain of the expectations of the group
the harder they are to stick to
especially in the long run maybe you can
do it for a day or a week or I don't
know a month or two but like at some
point you kind of keep rubbing against
that you have this like friction where
you're conflicting with the group and it
becomes hard to stick to that for the
long run and so the little takeaway that
I kind of think of now is
you want to join groups to join tribes
where your desired behavior is the
normal behavior because if it's normal
in that group then it becomes really
motivating to stick to it you know and
furthermore the the kind of like
ancillary habits that are part of that
group The the other expectations are
things that you're probably going to
soak up like
people will join a CrossFit gym because
they think they want to get in shape but
then you turn around six months later
and they're all eating paleo and wearing
the same brand of knee sleeves and they
buy the same workout gear and like it's
all these other habits that they never
intended to build but they just kind of
soaked them up because that's what the
group was doing and ultimately I think
this comes back to this kind of deep
need that we all have which is this need
to bond and connect you know we all want
to be a part of something we want to
belong we want to fit in and if people
have to choose between you know I have
habits that I don't really love but I
fit in I belong I'm part of something or
I have the habits that I want to have
but I'm cast out I'm ostracized I'm
criticized I mean most of the time the
desire to belong will overpower the
desire to improve so as best as possible
you got to get those two things aligned
and surround yourself with people where
your desired behavior is the normal
behavior
yeah absolutely
the whole you're the average of the five
people you associate with most type of
thinking and also for people who are
starting off the new year or about you
and thinking about
how to
best ensure that you cohere with a group
that
lead these to these new behaviors front
loaded make it painful not to do it pay
in advance
right make make some type of bet with
one of your friends and you owe each
other money if you miss workouts like
set it up so it is painful not to do it
I know that's might sound like I'm
favoring The Stick Over The Carrot
you're also going to use the carrots
right so you can use the carrots but
make it compelling from an incentives
perspective to do it as you said you can
also use the you know the carrots like
the the flip side of that is
so yes like make it painful not to do it
and make it easy and frictionless and
obvious to do it you know like try to
design your environment so the things
that you say are important to you are
the obvious and available things I think
one interesting thing you can do is walk
into the just think about one habit
you're trying to build and then walk
into the rooms where you spend most of
your time each day kitchen office
bedroom whatever and just look around
and ask yourself what behaviors are
obvious here you know what is this space
designed to encourage yeah and you'll
start to notice different things that
you can tweak to make it the good habit
more obvious and easier and the bad
habits or the things you want to avoid
less obvious and maybe a little higher
friction and making one or two little
adjustments like that is not going to
radically transform your life but if you
make a dozen or two dozen or 50 and
you're kind of all of these environments
all these rooms or you're spending space
each day are primed to support the
habits you want to build
I mean you know now you've got a
Tailwind rather than a headwind and so
it's become so much easier to appear as
if you have great willpower or that
you're really consistent when really
you're benefiting from the environment
that you already set up
yeah and I'll also say sometimes one or
two changes can make a huge difference
coming back to my brownie binge
yesterday
there's a reason I don't cook brownies
all the time right there's a reason I
don't have kids in my house because I
will eat all the [ __ ] chips I will
eat everything I love chips and I'd
rather than view that as a failing like
yes I could take the hard path and like
crawl on my knees through broken glass
to like develop the willpower to stare
at these chips every day and not eat
them or I can just not have the chips in
my pantry sure so these environmental
changes put yourself in positions to
succeed a lot of it is positioning you
know like if you have a dog and you're
walking it down the street and your dog
doesn't get along well with other dogs
and you see one coming toward you go to
the other side of the street don't like
put the dog in a bad situation you know
like you wouldn't and we that kind of
thing is obvious with our pets or with
our friends or our family members we're
like oh why would you do that to
yourself and then we do it to ourselves
all the time you know so like try to
design
a space where you are being served by
your environment rather than being
hindered by it yeah totally I think it
was I don't want to misquote them but
when I had Jerry Seinfeld on this show I
think he said
something like you know your mind is a
stupid little dog that you have to train
something along those lines and if you
think about it right I think now you got
me on dog training I think I'm dog
training a lot and I trained my dog
Molly and took it super seriously and
worked with all these different trainers
and then tried to modify it and so on
surprise surprise and they're they're
these basic things where it's like if
you talk to somebody and they have a
problem because their dog
choose shoes as an example and you can
ask well
where did the dog spend most of its time
for its first two months in the house as
a puppy and they'll be like oh I like
ran around the house I'm like where he
did your shoes on the floor yes that's
how the dog developed the habit of
chewing on shoes but if you crate train
your dog and you simply prevent them
from chewing on shoes for the first few
months they're not gonna eat shoes it's
just not going to be a thing generally
speaking and for humans too it's like if
you don't want to eat chips every day
it's in Paris then don't leave the shoes
on the floor don't leave the chips in
the pantry this is a solvable problem
and so I find a lot of reassurance in
the fact that it doesn't it doesn't have
to be
Brute Force willpower and I'm not saying
this to you because
in place of something nebulous like that
you can set up systems and you can also
rank order your habits in such a way
that you are looking for the Upstream
habits that make the downstream habits
easier right so whenever I've wanted to
get in better shape or someone has asked
me for advice they're like what should I
eat and I'm like let's talk about
exercise first because
if you eat well it doesn't necessarily
lead to exercise but if you exercise
very often you're not going to want to
spoil the exercise you did by eating a
bunch of crap right if you exercise
you're like wow I put in a lot of effort
I feel great
you're going to have this some costs
fallacy benefit of having put in that
effort you'll be less inclined to screw
it up there'll be too much cognitive
dissonance right
and in making those types of decisions
you you can actually make behavioral
change a lot easier for yourself and I'm
also looking at my environment I'm like
coffee coffee coffee coffee coffee
coffee
if I want to reduce my coffee
consumption maybe I should change this
room that I spend so much time in
my goodness anything else that you would
like to say James we've been going now
for
almost three hours and I think this is
probably a good place to begin to wind
down but is there anything else you'd
like to mention
the trajectory of your life bends in the
direction of your habits and a lot of
what we've talked about today whether
it's launching a book or writing a book
whether it's you know building an
exercise habit or a meditation habit
growing an email list or developing a
creative habit it comes back to
consistency it comes back to doing small
things well each day trying to live one
good day and then waking up again
tomorrow and doing the same thing and
the world is very results oriented and
that's fine you know like that we all
want to get better results but almost
all the results that you want are a
lagging measure of your habits so your
bank account is a lagging measure of
your financial habits your physical
fitness is a lagging measure of your
training habits your even like silly
stuff like the amount of clutter in your
living room is a lagging measure of your
cleaning habits you know so if you want
your results to change the habits that
precede them are the things that
actually need to change it's like fix
the inputs and the outputs will fix
themselves and
I don't think that means you have to be
radical about it you know it doesn't
mean that you have to upend your entire
life
really all you need to do is focus on
having like five good minutes you know
like you can do a lot with five good
minutes like five good minutes of
exercise can reset your mood five good
minutes of conversation can restore a
relationship five good minutes of
writing can make you feel great about
the manuscript again and so it doesn't
take much to feel good to get back on
the path to continue to make progress
and
small habits showing up in little ways
mastering the art of showing up trying
to get a little bit better each day
those are all things that you can keep
in mind as you try to just live one good
day today and be on a good trajectory
and that really one of the core ideas of
atomic habits is getting one percent
better today
and it's really about that it's really
not it's not about measuring it and like
it was a one percent Improvement or 1.6
or whatever it's it's not about the
numbers it's like a mindset it's a
philosophy it's an approach that I'm
going to focus on the trajectory that
I'm on I'm going to try to stay on a
good path even if it's just in small
ways and then trust that that will
compound and multiply and turn into
something much greater over time
because the truth is time will magnify
whatever you feed it you know if you
have good habits time becomes your Ally
and all you need is patience
but if you have bad habits time becomes
your enemy and every day that goes by
you kind of dig the hole a little bit
deeper and so
the idea is in atomic habits the
strategies for you know making small
changes for kind of letting these
behaviors improve over time
it's all about getting time to work for
you and I think you can start in really
small ways and begin to reinforce your
desired identity and hopefully this time
next year you'll be really happy with
where you're at in the progress you've
made
here here I'm not going to spoil that
with adding any commentary that is
unnecessary and that's a strong way to
close James clear you can find him at
jamesclere.com on Twitter and Instagram
at James Clear we'll link to everything
including the 321 newsletter which
everyone should check out in the show
notes as per usual Tim dot blog slash
podcast
James thanks so much for taking the time
this is great Took a ton of notes
I have homework
I have changes to make I have perhaps a
few bags of coffee to remove from my
immediate space
and this says rekindled
my enthusiasm Amplified my enthusiasm
for the new year so I appreciate you
caring so much and being so game to play
the tennis match of this conversation of
course thanks Tim really appreciate it
man
and to everybody listening
be just a little bit Kinder than is
necessary today that includes to
yourself set up systems remember our
dear friend ARCA Locus we will not rise
to the level of our goals or our hopes
but fall to the levels of our training
and our systems so best of luck to you
and thanks for tuning in